hi everyone welcome to this fantastic
video on eiml projects full cuse by
simply learn in this video we will clear
your doubts regarding the projects you
can add to your resume to clear the
interview or Advance your career in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting subscribe to our
Channel as we bring you the best videos
daily also hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn so
let's get started our inaugural project
sets the stage for the remarkable path
ahead the face recognition system after
that we will see how to predict
personality by implementing personality
prediction we will cover the speech
recognition system and after that we
will see the projects like fake news
detection and Loan Approval system
moving ahead we will see how to classify
image using CNN after which we will see
movie recommendation System enter a
world of algorithms that understand your
preferences and curate movie suggestions
tailor made for you moving ahead we will
see a Time series analysis and text to
speech converter system in the end we
will see object detection project so
buck
for an accelerating ride through the
realm of artificial intelligence machine
learning and Innovation on that note if
you want to become an AI expert and gain
handsome salary packages look at the
wide range of eiml courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in the
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT EXP explainable AI
machine learning algorithms supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and optimization and there is much more
on the list with hands-on experience in
the tools like chart GPT Dary python
open CV and T of low you will catch the
eye of top recruiters so what are you
waiting for hurry up and enroll now an
year of experience is preferred to
enroll in these courses find the course
Link in the description box so without
any further delay let's let's get
started so in today's session we will
see what open CV is moving forward we
will see what is Phase detection and at
the end we will go through the hands of
lab demo of how we can create phase
detection using open CV python we will
perform different function and use
different python libraries to create
phase detection before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss what open
CV is and proceed further for the same
what is open
CV a collection of python bindings
called open CV python was created to
address issue with the computer
vision python is general purpose
programming language created by guoon
rum that quickly gained popularity
largely due to it ease of use and
readable code the programmer can express
Concept in less code without sacrificing
readability numai a highly efficient
library for numerical operation with a
matlb like syntax is used by open CV
python numai arrays are translated into
and out of all open CV array forms
additionally this make it simpler to
interact with other numai using
libraries like scipi and matplot lip
after understanding what is open CV
let's move forward and see what phase
detection is so what is Phase
detection phase detection also known as
facial detection is a computer
technology that uses artificial
intelligence to find and recognize human
faces in digital
photographs pH deduction technology can
be enable realtime surveillance and
tracking of people in various Industries
such as security Biometrics law
enforcement entertainment and personal
safety from basic computer vision method
to developments in machine learning to
increasingly complex artificial neural
network and related Technologies phase
detection has advanced leading or to
ongoing performance
increases it now serves as the
foundation from some crucial application
such as face tracking face analysis face
recognition the application ability to
perform sequential tasks subst impacts
the phas
direction so dear learner if you want to
upskill your AI and machine learning
skills so give a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box
below so here is one question for you
guys I will give you exactly 1 minute
for this you can comment or give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so the question is which of the
following function is a buil-in function
in
Python
factorial print
seed
sqrt
so I am starting the timer of 1 minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section please do
let me know your
answers so I'm starting the timer of 1
minute which of the following function
is a buil-in function in Python
factorial print seed sqrt let us know
your answer in the comment section
below I kindly ask that everyone take
part in this
session which of the following function
is a built-in function in
Python 30 seconds more factorial print
seed
sqrt please let me know your answer in
the comment section
below 20 seconds
remaining
which of the following function is a
built-in function in
Python 10 seconds
more please let us know your answer in
the comment section
below so after the allotted time has
passed Those Who provided the current
response will receive a response and
those Who provided the incorrect
response will receive one so now let's
move to our programming part to create
phase detection using open CV
python so first we will open command
prompt to write a command to open
jupyter notebook so here we will write
Jupiter
notebook press
enter so this is the landing page of
jupyter notebook and here you have to
select new python
file so this is how the jupyter notebook
UI looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a phase
detection system so first let me rename
this
space
dection first we will import import
CV2 press enter then import another
Library import
numi as
NP and the third one is major One
Import face
[Music]
recognition SF
FR then press
enter so CV means capturing video the
CV2 function is a open CV can read video
video capture by using pass zero
function parameter we can access our
webcam we may pass as rtsp URL in the
function parameter to capture the CCTV
footage which is quite helpful for video
analysis and another one is numai napai
is a python Library used for working
with arrays it also has function for
working in the domain of linear algebra
and matrices it is an open- source
project you can use it freely numai
stand for numerical Python and the third
one is Phase recognition phase
recognition and manipulation using
python or the command line the easiest
facial recognition library in the world
built using Cutting Edge face
recognition technology from DLI
developed using deep learning so moving
forwards let's import our video capture
device so for that we have to write Here
video uncore capture this is our
variable
name equals
to CV2
Dot
video
capture and we have to pass here
zero then press
enter okay here
V should be
Capital so the video capture function
from open CV is used to interact with
the cameras what we can do is video can
be read shown and saved display the
image that the the camera
captured so moving forward let me import
my image for the further detection
process okay
so image equals to fr.
loore
image underscore
file
then image name or image path
boy.
jpg press
using load image file we can import
image file to our detection system so
moving forward let's set encoding for
the image okay so I will write here
image underscore phas underscore
encoding equals to F
dot
face
encodings
and
image than
zero press enter yeah so face encoding
basically uses 128 computer generated
measur to represent the face similar
encoding would be present in two images
of the same person while being
completely different in two images of
two distinct people so moving forward
let's do let me write first I will write
here
known
encodings equals to
image
face
coding okay then press enter Then
known
phase
names equals
to then here I have to put my name so I
will write
Bank okay then press enter so what I did
is I assigned known pH and codings to my
image face and coding so what will
happen if image matches to my face then
it will print my name and for the rest
we will add name unknown okay so let me
add the function now for phase detection
system so let me write the full code for
it first then I will explain you line
wise okay so just stay tuned with me I
will write here
so I will write
while okay
true okay so R comma frame I will
explain you line wise line don't worry
equals to then
video
capture do
read and
RGB underscore frame
equals
to
frame then
colon comma then again column comma then
two column then minus
one okay yeah so here I will write FC
underscore
locations equals to F do
face underscore
locations
RGB underscore
frame right here FC FC is for basically
phase and
codings alss to F
FR do
phore
encodings and
RGB under underscore
frame comma FC
underscore
locations okay so
for
top comma right comma
bottom comma
left okay then have to write your
face underscore
encoding comma face underscore encoding
this is that was encodings this is
encoding okay so before that I will
write
here okay
so
I have to write here
encoding IN
Zip okay then here I have to write FC
uncore locations
locations okay then comma then face
encodings
colon then press enter
so here I have to write
matches yes
yeah matches equals to f.
compare and
faces then
known underscore
phore
encodings
comma phore
encoding
okay
so it so what if the image will not
match so I have to give the name equals
to
unknown then we will write pH
distances equals to F do pH underscore
distances underscore
pH underscore
encodings comma base score and
coding then I will write match uncore
[Music]
index equals to NP
do a
r g
Min okay then I will write here FC
uncore
distances okay then moving forward
I WR
if
matches then match
uncore
index okay then colon then name equals
to known underscore
phas underscore
names then match uncore
index
and I have to write here
CV2 dot
rectangle and
frame
comma comma
top comma
right to give another bracket here
comma
bottom then
comma 0 comma 0 comma
255 again comma then two for the
border so then CV2 dot
rectangle
comma then
again left
comma
bottom then minus
35 okay so then I will
write
right comma
bottom comma then again 0 comma 0 comma
then CV2 do f i l d
field okay F should be
Capital
yeah so then we will set font equals to
CV2 dot
font
okay font
Dore
her
underscore
Simplex
okay so then I have to write
here
CV2 do
put
text
a comma
name
comma
left +
6 comma
bottom -
6 okay then comma
font comma
1.0 then again one comma then we have to
set location like
255 comma
255 then
comma
okay and here I have to write
CV2 do image show am
show then like simply
learn this
detection
comma
frame and
if CV2
dot weit
key is
one
and like 0
x
FF should be Capital FF equals to equals
to O then
quit and here I will write
break I will write
video undor
capture dot
release
TV2 dot
destroy
all
windows okay
yeah so let me explain you so in general
r r is a Boolean value that indicates
whether or not there was a even or
return each frame that is returned is at
the same frame if there is no frame you
will receive none rather than than an
error in open CV reading and writing
videos and reading and writing images
are quite similar a video is nothing
more than a collection of pictures often
known as
frames so to draw a rectangle around the
face that was discovered we utilize open
CV rectangle the rectangle function we
can draw the rectangle by using the
points or Corners position that the face
location
then en coding this a face en coding
this
one so a face encoding basically uses
128 computer generated measures to
represent the face similar and coding
would be present in two images of the
same person while being completely
different in two images of two distinct
people so this there is I use compare
phase so compare phas is used to compare
my face to uploaded image one okay if it
matches it will print my name otherwise
we have given unknown
here so the numai ARG AR this
one where it went this numai ARG
Min so the numi ARG Min method delivers
the indexes of the arrays minimum
element along each axis return an array
of array indices with the same shape of
the
array so this font where is yeah font
her
Simplex is normal size of senser font
okay so put text put text is used to put
the text on the frame like my name or
unknown so in order to display an image
in a window we use the IM show this
one this IM show
function okay so the window adjust
itself to the size of image parameters
window name a string that identifies the
window in which the displayed image will
appear Okay so until a key is pressed
weight key zero this one okay so until a
key is pressed weit key zero will will
keep the window open it is suitable for
image display and weit key one I write
here weight key 1 so weight key 1 will
show a frame for 1 ms before closing the
display on its
own so after the script has ended users
can close or remove all the windows use
the python like using destroy all
function function okay you would use the
function if you wanted to close a window
while it was open in numerous windows at
once so let's see our phase detection
system is working or not so let me close
this person on your screen first okay so
let me close this
first let me run
this now here you can see this popup and
I will open so here you can see my name
is currently
printing
okay
so like I have uploaded my image it's
directing correctly okay so like what if
I show uh one more image so here you can
see this is my
iard so it is detecting properly yeah so
what if I will show like another guy
image from my
mobile so here you can see it is
springing unknown in messy
photo
yeah so what if if I will write here
like uh one of the other image this
random. jpg then it should print unknown
for me also okay then I will run it
again okay it's working it'sing has come
so here you can see it is now printing
unknown because like I have uploaded
that another random image here so it is
importing okay so it is printing unknown
here so so here you can see like it's
spining unknown for me also so in
today's session we will go through Myers
bricks personalty prediction after that
a hands off La demo of how to predict
the person personality using Python and
machine learning we will perform
different function and different python
libraries so before we move on to the
programming part let's first discuss
what is Myers Brick's personality
prediction and proceed further for the
same so what is Myers brick personality
prediction
to better understand personality
characteristics in the broader
population the mbti examination was
created although there is no such thing
as Better or Worse personality
preference the MB examination can Aid
individuals in understanding their
strength weakness and potential
difference from the
others so there are some types of mbti
indicator there is no best or better
personality type than another it is not
a device made to search for
abnormalities and dysfunction it is sole
purpose is to assist you in discovering
more about yourself so there are four
separate skills make up the actual
questionnaire first is extrovert and
introversion second is sensing and
intuition third is thinking and feeling
fourth is judging and
perceiving So based in these four there
are some types so there are 16
types istj istp isfj isfp isfj like this
en NFP ENFJ entp and
entj so what is meaning of
istj I means introversion s means
sensing t means thinking and J means
judging like
these so dear Learners if you want to
upskill your AI and machine learning
skills so give yourself a chance to
Simply learn a professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning which
comes with completion certificate and
indepth knowledge of AI and machine
learning check this course detail from
the description box
below so now let's move to our
programming part so first we will open
command
prom first we will open command prom so
here I will add
Jupiter
enter so this is landing page of jupyter
notebook so here I will go new python
file this is how the python kernels look
like so here I will change
name B my big personality
prediction
okay
yeah at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
analyzing the data so here I will
write lo
li
p
r for numai as
NP
import pandas as
PD put M plot
Li P
plot as PLT
for
eor
SNS then
put
LLY do
offline
as okay then here
import
shortly
graph bgs object as
go
import
shortly do
tools as
DLS
from
bs4
import
beautiful then here I will write from SK
learn. model underscore
selection
Port
cross
valed
okay then again let me copy from here
till
import then here I will import straight
stratified
so
so here I will import
skar do
linear
model
put logistic
regression
so from
this we'll write here
skar
okay
learn do model uncore
selection
learn
dot
P
pleas
okay so here I will write more
from Lear do
decomposition
p
truncated
okay so here I will write
PR
skar
doore
section
text import
okay then from
Escalon do
pipeline both pipeline
from
Escalon
doace
multinomial nomial
NB
then py dot
init conect
itals
to is a python Library used for working
with arrays it also has a function for
working with domain of linear algebra
and matrices it is open source project
and you can use it freely n stand for
numerical python so panda is a software
Library written for the Panda's
programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operation
for manipulating numerical tables and
time series an open source python
Library based on matplot lib is called
cbor it is utilized for data exploration
and data visualization with data frames
and the pandas Library cbon function
with
these MPL lip for Python and its
numerical extension numai MPL lip is a
crossplatform data visualization and
graphical charting Pro as a result it
presents a strong open-source substitute
for metlab the API for met plot Li
allows programmers to incorporate graphs
into gii
application Beautiful soap python
software called Beautiful soup is called
Parts HTML and XML text for process
Pages it generates a pass tree that can
be used to extract HTML data for web
scraping pipeline the pipeline goal is
to put together several phases that can
be cross validate while using different
parameters moving forward let's import
some different data set you can download
these data set from the description box
below so here I will write
train to PD
dot
eore
CSV and then
here
PTI
one
do and second one is equals to PD do
read
_
ERS let
see
okay then there is one more equals
to PD
dot
P
see that
Forum
sages so here I will write
mbti equals
to
I key value so I'm writing a key
value
version
then
same
version get
done
[Music]
confusions
one t then t means
thinking f
means
heing
J
means
there
loading so still loading for data
set three different data set mbti 1 CSP
users and for messages you can download
these data set from the description box
below
okay or you can find this link for the
Drive
Link these are like last data set so it
will take time
sometime importing his data has done so
let's use shape function to see how many
rows columns are present in train data
set so here I will write
train dot
shape as you can see 865 8675 rows and
two
columns okay so let's move
forward so we to take a class I repeat
so we take a look to classes so it look
like very unbalanced data set so here I
will write
CNT do RS equals to
train
typ
counts so here I will plot do
figure
size 12a
4 so SNS do
barplot
[Music]
NS dot
values
0.8
plot dot y
leveles
size types different types than phont
size LT do show
here you can as you can see different
types of personality inj infj inp
inj so on okay so these are number of
occurrence and the
types
so moving forward let's group user ID
and messages so I will write
here better
visual yeah so here I will write
PS
message
message. fill an
yes
doore
join equals to PS do group
by
post
write
message
dot get here I will
write
all
Sor
hello
loading moving forward let's check
accuracy with different classifiers and
models so first we will check with extra
tree classifier
okay so for
that we write here like E tx. classifier
equals
[Music]
to classifier
then
underscore
estimators to 20 comma
Max to
Ops to
minus so here I will write TF
IDF
to let me copy it from
here and
[Music]
Gore
range
comma
upwards
SVD
component
D to
pipeline
have
I right
TFI I
here
there
here I will write K
folds
here I'm doing because of spelling
mistakes and
the to
five comma
Shuffle
and here I will write NP dot okay
sorry NP dot
random
in then type
write
scoring
TOS = to
minus it is still
loading
okay
now we will print so here I will write
print
EV then 0 4
F I will write
plus
minus
hold
on
0.4
FP
dot
mean
result
position
results
copy it all and CH
accordingly so now F1 score for F1 score
we will write here
F1
same
okay then here you have to write np.
mean that
is
accuracy here you will write test F1
uncore
micro okay then same
here test
F1 for the negative
losss
put I will write
negative
lore
loss
underscore
log
underscore done
it so wait let me make
it here you can see the accuracy and
it's it is not that good with xrt
classifier as the data set is very
unbalanced
F1 score is a better metric than
accuracy so we will check with some
alternative models so let's try if we
can find a more accuracy with model
another model although we haven't got a
lot of data so here I will write
DF
clean
T
okay so here I will write
text to
beautiful
oh the do
sub
then
R
oh
okay then text equals to r dot
sub
then
HTTP
SL
URL
text here I will addite
train
Post
post dot
fly in okay done so let's check accuracy
with first na base
okay oh I'm done with the code because
the code are mostly same so I just
copied it from my docents okay so let me
enter so here you can see uh the
accuracy is far better than this extra
classifier have okay so we will check
from one more we will let check for
logistic
regression so let me write the code
first then I will get back to
you I'm done with the code let's see the
accuracy of logistic
regression so let me press
enter loading you can
see
yeah so accuracy is far good than the
[Music]
both so is this model overfitting could
we have a better model with more data
let's see the learning curve okay so
here I will write train underscore
sizes comma train
underscore
scores
comma running underscore
curve
Post
in
type a
PS
jobs
toting equals
to here I write F1
underscore sies
= to
NP
space comma
State
one and press
enter okay this G
FS
dispatcher so for the learning curve it
is a long code so let me write it for
you again it's still
loading I don't know what
so I'm done with the code so let me run
it now let's see the
curve so for that let's set
import we
don't here I will write plot
learning rning
cve
po comma
train
typ
Tres in underscore
scores comma
test underscore
1.0 bigger size should
[Music]
be
sorry not
15 comma
pt.
show here as you can see training score
cross validation Score Learning graph
so it's look like that with more data
the mo model gets better and better so
that is not
overfitting so what we will
do moving forward let's see kaggle user
personality let's apply our model to
whole kaggle user commands let's see
what is the most common kle user
personality so for that I will write
here
psor join
then
comments
toore
join
message
dot
apply
nextt I will write model underscore
learning.
fit
train
type all equals to
model
Jo it's loading here so moving forward
what what we will do let's create a bar
graph to see kagle user personality
okay
loading it will show the warning
something
like let me write the code for the
paragraph okay it's a long code so I
will write first then I will get back to
you
oh I wrote the code so let me run it and
see the
personality so here you can see esfp is
the most used
personality so let's see the uh count
personalty count percentage count for
that I will write
here
underscore
DF percent
fiction _
DF
count underscore DF then again
count
okay where I will write prediction
underscore
TF
description
personality like
the
X
join PTI
one
just
okay here you can see the percentage
count for every
personality okay with description exion
sensing feeling perceiving
ESF
so finally at the end we will see the
personality distribution using pie chart
okay so here I will write labels equals
to
prediction _
TF I will write
description
okay size
isal to prediction underscore
dm%
spal to go dot
IAL to
labels
comma
use to sizes
layout should be layout equals to go dot
layouts
to kle user
alties
data equals
to
trace
that dot
data to
data y Dot
iplot
okay let me run
it let me run
it here you can see the pie
chart so like most 50% is
esfp okay then 23 is introversion to
ution then so on okay so everything is
written here and every
color so apparently the most common kle
user personality is esfp this
50.6% okay so extroversion sensing
feeling perceiving but we are getting
this conclusion based on user's command
it is reasonable to think that user who
participate more writing comments are
more extrovert our sample data don't
come from the kaggle users population it
is only based on the
comments it comes from the kagle users
comments so our conclusion can't be
applied to all kagle user so like more
accuracy models could be obtained the
more data if you want to become an AI
expert and gain handsome salary packages
look at the wide range of e IML courses
by simply learn in collaboration with
top universities across the globe so
what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now and year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses
find the course Link in the description
box so in today's session we will go
through what is a speech recognition
system moving forward we will see how
speech recognition system works after
that we will create a speech recognition
system using python we will perform
different function and create speech
recognition system using different
python libraries before we move on to
the programming part let's discuss what
is the speech recognition system first
and proceed further for the
same what is a speech recognition
system a program capacity to convert
spoken language into written language is
known as a speech recognition system
also known as automatic speech
recognition computer voice recognition
or speech to text despite being
sometimes confused with voice
recognition speech recognition focus on
converting speech form a verbal to a
text format whereas voice recognition
only aims to distinguish The Voice voice
of a certain
person voice and speech recognition are
two distinct Technologies and they
shouldn't be confused to recognize word
in spoken language speech recognition is
used voice recognition uses biometrical
Technologies to recognize a specific
person by their
voice so after knowing what is speech
recognition system let's move forward
and see how does the speech recognition
system
work peace recognition in Python works
with algorithm that perform linguistic
and acostic modeling acostic modeling is
used to recognize phonetics in our
speech to get the more significant part
of speech as words and sentences speech
recognition start by taking the sound
energy produced by the person speaking
and converting it into the electrical
energy with the help of microphone it
then convert the electrical energy from
analog to digital and finally to the
text it breaks the audio data down into
sounds and it analyze the sound using
algorithm to find the most probable word
that fits that audio all of this is done
using natural language processing NLP
and neural networks hidden Mark models
can be used to find temporal patterns in
speech and improve accuracy so here is
one question for you guys I will give
you 1 minute for this you can comment or
you can give your answer in the chat
section so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or wrong I'm
repeating again so here is one question
for you guys I will give you exactly 1
minute for this you can comment or you
can give answer in the chat section so I
can see if the answers given by you are
right or wrong so the question is which
of the following is the correct
extension for the python
file I'm repeating again which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file option A do python
option
BPL option C py and option
DP so let us know your answer in the
comment section below so I'm starting a
timer of 1 minute just type your answer
in the comment section or in the chat
section do let me know your answers
please I kindly ask that everyone take
part in this to make this live session
exciting so I'm starting the
timer
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so the question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python
file 37 seconds meaning option a python
option BPL option C py option D
dop let us know your answer in the
comment section
below I can't ask that everyone take
part in this to make the live session
exciting you have 15 seconds
remaining 10 seconds
more which of the following is the
correct extension of the Python file 3 2
1 after that allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the correct response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one okay so now let's move to
our programming part to create a speech
recognition system using python so first
we will open a command prom to write a
command to open Jupiter notebook so here
we will write
Jupiter
notebook press
enter
so this is the landing page of jupyter
notebook and here you can select new
python
file so this is how the jupyter notebook
UI looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a speech
recognition system so here we will write
first let me REM remain rename
this speech
Rec
so first I will import
import
spe
underscore
recognition and second
import pyttsx3
present enter so the incredibly
extension I repeat the incredibly
extensible speech recognition Library
serves as a rapper for a number of
well-known speech apis the speech
recognition Library includes default API
key for one of these the Google web
speech API hardcoded that implies that
you can start moving without needing to
register for a service and python
project would benefit greatly from using
the speech recognition package due to
its versality and
usability and then pyttsx3 a python text
to speech conversion library is called
pyttsx3
it is compatible with python 2 and
Python 3 and work offline unlike
competing libraries to obtain a
reference to a pyttsx3 engine instance
an application calls the pyttsx3 in it
it is very userfriendly program that
turns type text to into
speech so moving forward let's write
code for actual speech recognition
system so here I will
write Sr equals to to
speech
underscore
recognition dot
recognizer R must be Capital
here
yeah here I will write with
speech
underscore
recognition dot microphone
Source
two then
colon
yeah
here I will write
print we'll write here okay silence
please okay then I will write here Sr do
adjust underscore 4
underscore
ambient underscore
noise then Source 2 comma
duration equals to
two Okay then enter then I will print
something
like
peek now
please something like that then I will
write here
audio audio
2 equals to
Sr Dot
listen source
to
and here I will write for text equals to
Sr
dot
recognize
okay
underscore
Google audio
2 then here I have to print the small
letters in lower case so I will write
here text x equals to
text do
lower
this then here I will write
print it you
say
plus text
uh everything look
great so a recognizer is a machine
ability to listen to spoken words and
identify them you can then use a speech
recognition in Python to convert the
spoken words into text make a query or a
give a reply you can even program some
devices to respond to these spoken words
like every time the recognized speech
from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the edges for
ambient noise this one for ambient noise
the backlog parameter of the listen
function allow a qu size to be specified
it will listen to what we are speaking
or
saying this recognize Google a function
on the recognizer class which you have
now developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and convert spoken
words into text recognize Google needs
the argument audio data in order to
function prop L otherwise it will
fail python built-in function lower is
mostly used to handle strings the lower
method converts each Capital character
in The provided string to lower case
before returning the lower cost string
it accept no arguments it return to the
original text if the supplied string has
no capital letters now let's check
whether it's working or not so I will
run it yeah run
all
hello how are you
doing yeah you can see hello how are you
doing
printed so let me try another
one subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply
learn
so here you can see subscribe to Simply
learn YouTube channel and press that
Bell icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn is
printed so speech to text is working
fine so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
queries regarding any code or you have
any questions just put as in comments
our team will shortly provide you with
the correct solution now moving forward
what if you want that system will write
what we are saying and speak that to
this will be printed and now moving
forward what if you want that system
will write what we are saying and speak
that too so for that we will write a
small line of code so first we will
do we will create one here like we will
insert cell below we will write a
function here so
DF Speak
Now
command
colon then voice equals
to pytt
sx3 do
init okay then voice do
say
command and
voice do run and
wait
yeah so what we will do
here we will write like
speak
now
then so this voice is nothing just a
variable to text to spe an in8 py tx3
engine has started obtains a pointer to
an instance of an engine that will
utilize the specified driver if another
engine instance is already using the
given driver the other engine instance
is returned if not a new engine is built
is speak now is a function in which
using get function I'm getting the
values of the text this one I will get
now let's run this sort of code and
let's see if it is working or not so I
will
run
hello how are you
all speak now is not defined
okay speak now okay and is
small okay my B run this
again hello how are you all
hello how are you all I hope you can
hear properly so let
me run this again for another demo
example subscribe to Simply Lear YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply
learn subscribe to simple and YouTube
channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from simple learn yeah
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any queries
regarding any code or you have any
question related to python just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you with the correct solution
okay okay moving forward so at last
let's create a speech recognition system
from which we can open our websites and
all like YouTube like Facebook like
simply learn anything thing so we will
open open new file for this I will
create the separate
one here I will write speech to web
webites
okay
speech to
web so here I will import import speech
underscore
recognition then import pyttsx3
then one major Library
import web
browser okay then I will run it yeah I
hope you already know these to first two
libraries so this is third librar is
used for web browser is the file source
code the web browser modules offers a
high level user interface that enables
user to view web based content in most
cases executing the open function from
the this module will result in the
desired
outcome so moving forward let me write
code for it so I will write code first
then I will explain you line wise so I
will write
if uncore
uncore name then again toore equals to
equals
to underscore main then again
underscore then
colon yeah then you have to give a path
like for your browser you can use Edge
you can use Google Chrome anything
Firefox anything so here I will give
path path equals to
then C drive I have my path
already
program
files and x
Microsoft and Edge
then
application then
msh do
exe you have to write at the end this
percentage
s don't forget to write this okay so
path is set so let me create Sr equals
to
speech recognition
dot
recognizer same as previous
one and I will write with speech
underscore
recognition dot
microphone as
source
then sr.
adjust
for
ambient
noise then
Source now everything seems
good let me write
print but we have wrote there like speak
now please so here I will
write
please say
something to
open
okay I will write
audio equals to sr.
listen listen
that
source and I will
print like what you
said so it will hear
[Music]
hearing then I will here I try and
accept then try so here I will write
destination equals to
Sr
recognize _
Google then
audio
in where you
asked to
open write here plus destination
okay so then
web
browser we browser dot get that
path then
open that
destination
destination okay so here I will write
that
accept
exception
as you can write
e then
print if there will be
error
sta
e
okay so a recognizer is a machine
ability to listen to spoke converts and
identify them you can use speech
recognition in Python to convert the
spoken word into text you can even
program some devices to respond to these
spoken words every time the recognized
speech from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the adjust ambient
noise method a socket is already to
receive connection after calling the
listen function prior to performing the
accept method on the server soet the
listen method should be called the
backlog parameter of the listen function
allow a q size to be specified it will
listen to what we are speaking or
saying the recognize Google function on
the recognizer class which you have now
developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and will convert
spoken words into text recognize Google
needs the argument audio data in order
to function properly otherwise it will
fail okay
so okay so let's try this it's working
or not let me run
this okay invalid syntax perhaps you
forgot a
comma let me
see that print
error think it should be here
okay let me check
this
let me run this
again valid syntax perhaps you forgot a
comma
okay try to run this
again
two
okay let me remove this I guess it will
work fine
still did input okay okay no
issues so here I will write again
accept
exception
e
in
errors R okay I forgot to write plus
okay okay
e yeah now it will work
fine
www.youtube.com here you can see YouTube
is
open yeah so we will try this one more
time
www.fb.com
so here you can see Facebook is open
ww.facebook.com
one more last
time www.s
simply.com
so in today's session we will discuss
what fake news is and at the end we will
do a hands-off lab demo of how to detect
fake news using machine
learning before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss first
what fake news is and proceed further
for the same what is fake news false or
misleading information that is reported
as news is called fake news a common
goal or fake news is to harm someone or
something reputation or to profit
through
advertising the term fake news was first
used in 1890s a time when dramatic
newspaper reports were common even
though incorrect information has always
been dissed throughout
history however the phrase has no clear
definition and is often used to refer to
all misleading information high-profile
individuals have also used it to refer
to any news that is not favorable to
them
so dear Learners if you want to upscale
your AI and machine learning skills so
give yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with a
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course details from the
description box below now let's move to
our programming
part so first we will open a command
prom to write a command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write
Jupiter notebook
Center and here I have to select new
python Kel file okay so this is how the
Kel look lies so first we will import
some major libraries of python so here I
will write
import pandas as
PD and import
numai as
NP then
import
cbor as
SNS okay then
import
skarn dot model
selection ort
train
underscore test underscore
split before that I will
import mat plot
Li P
plot as
PLT okay
then I will write here from SK
Kar dot
matrix
import
accuracy
four then
from
Escalon do
Matrix
import
classification to report
and import R then import
string
okay then press enter so it is
saying okay here I have to write
from everything seems
good
loading let's
see okay till then numai is a python
Library used for working with arrays it
also has function for working with the
domain of linear algebra and
matrices it is an open source project
and you can use it
freely number stand for numerical
python pandas so panda is a software
Library written for Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structure and operation for manipulating
numerical tables and time
series then cbor an open- Source python
Library based on M plot lib is called
cbon it is utilized for data exploration
and data visualization with data frames
and the pandas Library cbon functions
with ease then M PL lip for Python and
its numerical extension numpy met plot
Li is a cross platform for the data
visualization and graph iCal charting
package as a result it presents a strong
open source suitable for metlab the apis
for met plot live allow programmers to
incorporate graphs into gii applications
then this train test is split we may
build our training data and the test
data with the aid of Escalon train test
split function this is so because the
original data set often serves as both
the training data and the test data
starting with the single data set we
divide it into two data sets to obtain
the information needed to create a model
like hor and test accuracy score the
accuracy score is used to gge the
model's Effectiveness by calculating the
ratio of total true positive to Total
true negative across all the model
prediction this re regular expression
the functions in the model allow you to
determine whether a given text fits a
given regular expression or not which is
known as
re okay then a string a collection of
letters words or other character is
called a string it is one of the basic
data structure that serves as the
foundation of manipulating data the Str
Str class is a built-in string class in
Python because python strings are
immutable they cannot be modified after
they have been
formed okay so now let's import the data
set we will be going to import two data
set one for the fake news and one for
the True News or you can say not fake
news okay so I will write here
efcore fake equals
to PD
do read uncore
CSV or what can I say DF fake
okay tore fake
okay then fake do CSV you can download
this data set from the description box
below then data dot true equals to PD do
read _
CSV sorry
CSV then fake news sorry true true. CSV
okay then press
enter so these are the two data set you
can download these data set from the
description box below so let's see the
board data set okay then I will write
here
dataor
fake do
head so this is the fake data okay
then
data uncore
true
do and this is the two
data okay this is not fake so if you
want to see your top five rows of the
particular data set you can use head and
if you want to see the last five rows of
the data set you can use tail instead of
head okay
so let me give some space for the better
visual so now we will insert column
class as a Target feature okay then I
will write here data let go
fake
plus equals
to0 then data underscore
true and
cross = to
okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake dot shape and data underscore
true do
shap okay then press
enter so the shape method return the
shape of an array the shape is a tle of
integers these number represent the
length of the corresponding area
dimension in other words a tle
containing the quantities of entries on
each axis is an array shape Dimension so
what's the meaning of
shape in the fake word in this data set
we have 2 3 4 8 1 rows and five columns
and in this data set true we have 2 1 41
7 rows and five column okay so these are
the rows column rows column for the
particular data set
so now let's move and let's remove the
last 10 rows for the manual testing okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake let's go
manual
testing to dataor
fake.
tail
for the last 10 rows I have to write
here
10 okay so for I in
range 2 3
4 8 1 sorry
0o comma 2
470 comma
minus1 okay
and DF underscore not DF
data underscore
fig dot
drop
one instead of one I can write here
I comma
is equals
to0 in
place equals to
true then
data not
here data
underscore same I will write for I will
copy from here
and I will paste it here and I will make
the particular changes so here I can
write
true where I can write
true
okay then I have to change a
[Music]
number
write 21 4
6 minus
one
same so press
enter X =
to0
in X maybe you mean d0 or of
this okay we will put here double
course I'm putting
this
. drop i z in place
okay also write equals to and equals
to yeah
so okay AIS is not
defined now it's working
so let me see
now data
underscore pick.
shape
okay and data dot
true and data underscore
true do
shape as you can
see 10 rows are deleted from each data
set yeah so I will write here data
underscore fake underscore
manual
testing
class equal
to0 and data
underscore true
_ manual _
testing plus equals to
okay just ignore this
warning then let's
see data
underscore B underscore menu
well testing
doad as you can see we have this and
then data dot sorry underscore
truecore
manual
testing dot at
okay
this is this is the uh true data
set so here I will merge
data go
merge
to PD
dot
concat concat is used for the
conation dataor
fake
data
underscore comma
XIs =
to0 then data uncore
merge do
head the top 10
rows
yeah as you can see the data is merged
here okay first it will come for the
fake news and then with the for the True
News then let's merge true and fake data
frames
okay we did this
and let's Mery column then data do
merge
dot columns or let's see the
columns it has not defined what data
underscore
March these are the column same title
Tex subject date class
okay
now let's remove those columns which are
not required for the further process so
so here I will write data
underscore or equals to data underscore
March
prop title we don't
need
then subject we don't need
then
so
one so let's check some null
values it's giving
error because of
this that's good then
data
dot is
null
Su
Center so no null values okay then let's
do the random shuffling of the data
frames okay for that we have to write
here data equals to data do
sample
one
then data okay
data do
head okay now you can see here the
random shuffling is
done and one for the true data set and
zero for the fake news one
okay then let me write here data
dot
reset _
index
Place equals to
True data dot
drop comma X is = to 1
then comma in
place equals to
True
okay then let me see columns now data do
columns so here we have two columns only
rest we have deleted
okay
so me see data do
add yeah everything seems
good let's proceed further and let's
create a function to process the text
okay for that I will write
[Music]
here
but okay you can use any
name
text and text equals
to text do
lower okay and
text to r dot for the
substring remove these
things uh from
the datas okay so for that I'm writing
herea okay then text equals to
R do
substring
comma comma
text okay then I have to write text
equals
to do
subring
W
ww
dot
s+
comma comma text
okay then text equals
to I do
subing
then
okay then text equals to R do
substring
then
percentage
s again percentage
for r. SK
function right here
string do
punctuation
okay
comma then comma then
text
right then text equals to so R do
substring and
N
comma Tex equals to r
dot
substring right
here
then again
D then
again
okay then
comma and again text here okay then at
the end I have to write here return text
so everything like uh this this type of
special character will be removed from
the data set okay let's run this let's
see
yeah so here I will addite DF sorry not
DF
data
then
text to
data dot
apply do the function name wordp word
opt
okay press enter yeah so now let's uh
Define the dependent and independent
variables okay x equal to
data
text and Y =
to
data
class okay then splitting training and
testing
data okay sorry so here I will write
xcore
train comma xcore
test uh then Yore
train comma Yore test equals to train
underscore testore
split then X comma
y comma
test let's go
size equals to
0.25 okay press
enter so now let's convert X to vectors
for that I have to write
here that is
X so here I will write from
Escalon dot
feature
extraction dot text
import T
vectorizer
okay then
vectorization equals to T fid
vectorizer okay
then V
underscore
train equals
to
vectorization i1 vectorization do
fit then
transform
xcore
train okay then X Vore test equals
to
factorization dot
transform xcore test okay then press
enter uh
so now let's see our first model
logistic
regression so here I will write
from Escalon
dot linear underscore
model OKAY
import
logistic
then
lals
to
logistic
regression and after write here LR
dot
fit then XV
dot not DOT train comma
X Vore
test okay
Center xv.
TR okay here I have to write y
train okay and press
enter will work so here I will write
prediction
underscore Le linear
regression equal
to l r do
predict Vore
test okay let's see the accuracy
score for that I have to write LR DOT
score then XV underscore
test comma yore
test okay let's see the accuracy so here
as you can see accuracy is quite good
98% now let's
print the
classification
P Yore test comma
prediction of linear regression
okay so this is you can see Precision
score then F1 score then support value
accuracy okay so now we will uh do this
same for the decision tree gradient
boosting classifier random Forest
classifier okay then we will do model
testing then we will predict this
score okay so now for the decision tree
classification so for that I have to
import from
skar dot
Tre
import
decision
three
classifier okay then at the short form I
will write here copy it from
here
then
okay then I have to write the same as
this so I will copy it from
here
and
yeah let's change linear regression
to is three
classific
okay then I will write here
same go
DT dt.
predict X
Vore
test
still loading it's it will take
time
okay till then let me write here for the
accuracy it do
score
Vore test comma
y let's wait okay
run the accuracy so as you can see
accuracy is good than this linear
regression okay logistic
regression okay so let
me show you the let me
predict
print
so this is the accuracy score this is
the all the
report
yeah now let's move for the uh gradient
boosting
classifier okay for that I write from
escon dot
assemble port
radiant
boosting
classifier
classifier I will write here
GB equals to let me copy it from
here
okay will give here random let go
State equals to
zero wait wait wait wait so I will write
here GB dot
fit X Vore train comma Yore train okay
then press
enter
here I will write predict underscore
GBS to GB
doit sorry
redit
three DOT
test doore
test till then it's loading so I will
write here uh for the score then I will
addite G GB
doore then Vore test
comma Yore test okay so let's wait it is
running this
part and then let me write for the
printing
this
okay it's taking
time taking time still taking
time what if I will run
this it's not coming because of
this yeah it's done now so you can see
the accuracies
is uh not good than
decision tree but yeah it is also good
99.4 something okay
so now let's check for the last one
random
Forest first I will
do for the random Forest we have to
write from Escalon
dot
symble
import
random
Forest
classifier
okay and here I will write
RF plus
to right I will copy it from
here then
random
State equals
to Z
then RF dot
fit Spore
train comma Yore
train okay then press
enter and predict underscore
RC
RF equals
to rf.
predict 3core test
okay till then I will write here it's
still loading it will take time so till
then I will write for the score score
accuracy
score XV uncore test comma Yore
test okay then I will write here till
then
print
classification
put and Yore
test
comma
it will take time little
bit
so uh it run the accuracy score is 99 it
is also
good so now I will write the code for
the model testing so I will get back to
you but after writing the code
so so I have made two functions one for
the output label and one for the manual
testing okay
so it will predict the all the from the
all models from
the repeat so it will
predict the it the news is fake or not
from all the models okay so for that let
me write here
news to
string
put
okay then I will write here manual
underscore
testing
okay
so here I will you can add any news from
the you can copy it from the Internet or
whatever from wherever you want so I'm
just copying from the internet
okay from the Google the news which is
not fake okay I'm adding which is not
fake because I already know I searched
on Google so I'm entering this so just
run it let's see what is
showing okay string input object is not
callable okay let me check this
first
yeah I have to give here s strr
only yeah let's check okay I have to add
here again the script yeah manual
testing is not
defined let me see manual
testing okay I have to edit
something it is just GB and it is just
RF GBC is not defined okay okay so what
I have to do I have to remove
this
this okay everything seems
sorted
now
as I said to you I just copied this news
from the internet I already know the
news is not fake so it is showing not a
fake news okay so now what I will do I
will
copy one fake news from the
internet and let's see it is detecting
it or not okay
so let me run
this and let me add the news for
this
so all the models are predicting right
it is a fake news or you can add your
own script like this is the fake news
okay I hope you guys understand till
here so I hope you guys must have
understand
how to detect a fake news using machine
learning you can you can copy it any
news from the internet and you can check
it is fake or not okay or if your model
is predicting right or not if you want
to become an AI expert and gain handsome
salary packages look at the wide range
of e IML courses by simply learn in
collaboration with top universities
across the globe so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll now an year of
experience is preferred to to enroll in
these courses find the course Link in
the description box in today's session
we will go through what is loan
prediction system after that we will
move on to the hands of lab demo to
perform loan approval prediction system
moving forward we will be using
different classification algorithms to
implement loan approval prediction
system we already have a loan approval
data set with us we will perform
different function and libraries using
python you can download this data set
from the description box below
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what is loan
prediction system first and proceed
further for the same a mechanism called
loan prediction system gives you a way
to apply for loans and receive
notification when they are approved in
accordance with the data provided by the
applicant the system notifies the
applicant of the loans available so here
is one question for you guys I will give
you one minute for this you can comment
or you can give your answer in the chat
section so I can see if the answer given
by you are right right or wrong I'm
repeating again so here is one question
for you I will give you one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answers given by you are
right or wrong so the question is which
keyword is used for function in Python
language option one python option two DF
option C
fnc option D
Define so let us know your answer in the
comment section below okay
so I'm starting of timer 1 minutes type
your answer in the comment section or in
the chat section do let me know your
answers please I kindly ask that
everyone take part in this to make this
live session exciting so I'm starting
the timer of 1
minute which keyword is used for
function in Python language option one
function option two def option C Funk
option D Define
fine which keyword is used for function
in Python
language 47 can
remaining 30 seconds let us know your
answer in the comment section
below this is the easy one which keyword
is used for function in Python language
function Dev Funk or Define
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this
exciting second
more yeah after that a lotted time has
passed Those Who provided the correct
response will re receive a response and
those Who provided the incorrect
response will Rees
one so now let's move to our programming
part to implement loan approval
prediction system so first we will open
a command prom to write a command to
open jupyter notebook so here we will
write
Jupiter
notebook press
enter so this is the landing page of
jupyter notebook and here you have to
select new Python 3 file
this is how the jupyter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us creating a loan approval
prediction system so here I will write
import
numai as
NP so numai is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in domain of linear
Al albra and matrices it is an
open-source project and you can use it
freely numai stand for numerical
Python and the second one
is
Port pandas SD panda is a software
Library written for the Python
programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data struction and operations
for manipulating numerical tables and
Time
series and the third one is
import matplot
lip P
plot as
PLT so M plotly Python scripts can be
used to create 2D graphs and plots using
the matplot LA module with features to
control line Styles font attributes
formatting AIS and other features it
offers a module called pip plot that
makes simple for
plotting so the fourth one
is
import
cbor as
SNS so cbone an open source python
Library based on M plot Li is called
cbone it is utilized for data
exploration and data visualization with
data frames and the pandas Library c one
function with these
so there is one more like
prom
Escalon
Port
svm so after importing libraries let's
move forward and import data set so DF
equals
to pd.
rore
CSV
phone.
CSV you can download this data set from
the description box
below so
yeah so data set is imported let's see
our data set so we will write DF do
head
here yeah here you can see we have data
set of top five rows so basically head
is used for showing first five rows of
the data set if we will use tail instead
of head so it will show the last five
rows of the data set so let's move
forward and use info function to see the
information about the data
set okay so here we will write DF
doino so the data frame information is
printed by the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use range
index and the number of cells in each
column that is non-null values note that
the info method does indeed print the
information okay so here you can see
loan ID is
object then this applicant income is
N64 then co- applicant income is float
so nonnull values like
this so we know all the column names
data types and information let's move
forward and see missing values in the
data set so for that we will use here I
will write DF dot is
null then
bases dot
sum yeah isnel do sum the data set total
number of missing values is returned bya
sum es skip rows in the data set that
have missing values as a straightforward
solution for the missing value
data so we have missing values in loan
ID is zero gender is 13 then loan amount
is 22 self-employed is
32 so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code so just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution I'm
repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
questions or any query regarding any
code or any question related to python
just put as in commments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
moving forward we will create one more
column that is loan amount log using
loan amount detail and then we will
display a histogram for that okay so let
me do first for the better view I can do
this yeah I will write here
DF
loone
amount _
log Yeahs to
NP do
logf now we will do
DF
loan amount underscore log
do his for the histogram then bins I
will
take
20. log a mathematical function that
helps user to calculate natural
logarithms of X where X belongs to all
the input array elements you can see
histograms it's looking fine let's see
the null values in our new column so I
will write right
here PF dot is
null
sum so here you can see in loan amount
log there are 22 missing
values so moving forward let's create
one more column named total income in
this we will add two columns applicant
income and co- applicant income and we
will display histogram for the same
EF like total
income equals to
DF applicant
income and we will add one more data FR
TF
that
is co
applicant
F total
income underscore
log to NP
DOT
log
DF
toal
income underscore
log
HT P equals to
20 yeah so here you can
see histogram of the total income log
moving forward let's fill those null
values in all the respective columns so
here for that we will
write
DF
gender fill and
na
DF
gender dot
mode
zero comma in
place to
true and what I will do I will copy from
here change here gender to
married also
married and here for selfemployed
I will do
self
deployed for
dependent just everything will be same
so here I will write DF
Dot
loan
amounts
to DF
dot loan
amount fill
na BF dot loan
amount do
me
so here I will write instead of this I
will copy from here and paste it here
yeah SC
log l is
small
so here I will write again that we can
take it from
here change column
name to
loan
amount
um
on
amount
some credit underscore
history
again credit
underscore
history
so here I will write DF dot is
null
some it's it's for giving
error s selfemployed
okay what the isue is that E
capital
in
dependent okay okay it's
dependence
okay yeah so there is no missing values
now what we going to do is we will
select some specific columns and Row for
the training and testing so for that I
will write
here x =
to dot
iock dot
r
column
11 comma 13 column
15 DOT
values y = to DF dot
iog then colum comma
12 dot
values let me see the X
values okay okay so male no these are
the X values and let me see the Y
values okay so the iog function in
Python is defined in the pandas module
that helps us to select a specific row
or column from the data set using the
iog method in Python we can easily
retrieve any particular value from a row
or column by using index values so
moving forward let's see the percentage
of missing genders from the data set and
we will do it for many other
columns okay so it if it will be zero so
it will be great for us so we will write
print
percent
of
missing
gender
is percent
to f
then we will write
thisf in gender
column is
null dot
sum F do
shape
zero
multiply by
100 is saying function object has no
attribute
sum okay
why
because
here percent of missing gender is zero
great so like uh so moving forward we
will see number of people who take loan
as a group by
gender okay so for that we will write
print numbers like of
people who take loan as
Group by
gender for
that
print
DF
sender dot
value value
counts SS do
count
plot x equals
to
Sender
comma data equals to DF
valet equals to set one you can use
either set two either set
three let me see okay so here you can
see like male is 502 female are 112 you
can see the bar plot so the number of
observation in each category beans are
displayed using bars using the count
plot technique the following parameters
are accepted by the procedure and are
listed below this parameter accept
optional variable names for data or
vector data inputs for long form data
plotting so moving forward we will do
for the same like number of people who
take a loan Group by medal status so
what I will do I will just copy from
here and I will change it to
here so I will
write my
status and the guys were
married here I have to write
the
eight so here you can see like
401 are yes like and 213 are
no
okay so moving forward we will see
number of people who T loan Group by
dependents so same what I will do I will
paste it here I will just change the
name
here
[Music]
dependence change it to
here
here you can see the dependent and the Y
label is the count so like Z are 360 102
101 and 51 and many more so moving
forward we will see number of people who
take loan group as a
self-employed okay for that what we have
to do is we have to just change names
e is capital
here okay let's see the graph so mov
forward we will see number of people who
take loan Group by loan amount for that
I have to write
here wait let me make a better
visibility yeah so as a loan
[Music]
amount
don't
mount
Capital
yeah here you can
see bar
graph so at the end we will see the
number of people who take loan Group by
credit
history okay so I will write
here
same
as credit
history credit
history
three credit
underscore
history
okay yeah so here you can see 525
and this
89 So based on my assessment we don't
have any missing values in the data set
now so moving forward let's import
psychic learn library for training and
testing data set so here I will write
from Escalon do
model
underscore
selection
Port
train underscore test underscore
split so here we WR train comma X test
comma y train comma
y
test
okay so here I will
write
train underscore test underscore
split comma
y comma
test underscore
size equals to
0.2
random
State equals to
Zero from
SK SK
learn dot
preprocessing
processing import
label
encoder okay so
label score X = to
label
encoder SK
learn
my
bad X is not
defined
there we
have
psychic learn or SK learn is the one of
the most robust library for machine
learning it is open source and built
upon numai scipi and M plot lip it
provides a range of tools of machine
learning and statical modeling and train
test split function of the skarn model
selection package in Python splits
arrays or matrices into random subsets
for train and test data and label
encoder encode label with a value
between zero and N classes minus one
where n is the number of distinct
label moving forward let's fit and
transfer data for
training so here we will write
for I
in I in
range 0 comma
5 xcore train
I equals to
label and
orderer underscore X do
fit
transform and xcore
train colon comma
I then xcore
train
7 equals
to
_
x dot
fit
transform underscore
train
7 let's see X
underscore oh
sorry go
train and yeah this
I this is capital
x with transform joins these two steps
and use for the initial fitting of the
parameter on the trating set while also
returning the transform X internally the
transform object just calls first fit
and then transform on the same data and
we will
perform same for the Y so I have I will
write
here encoder _
y
label
encoder
okay Yore
10 equals to label
encoder underscore y do
fitore
transform see the results
yeah so training of the data set is done
let's do for same for the testing data
so I will write here for I in
range 0 comma
5 underscore
test
I equals to label
_ X do
fitore
transform underscore
test
I then again
xcore
test col comma
7 equals to
label
encoder
underscore dot
fitore
transform _
test then colum comma
7 yeah and see the results xcore
okay it seems good all the
values so we will do for the same y
test so we will write here
label and
coder let me
put y to
labeler
so Yore test equals
to
_ Y do
fitcore
transform underscore
test just let's
see
okay moving forward we will import
standard Scala for the further process
so for that we will write
here from
Escalon do
preprocessing
import
[Music]
standard
scalar say
to like assign this
standard I will do I will copy it from
here so X
train equals to ss.
fitore
transform
xcore
TR then xcore test equals to SS do
fitore
transform underscore
test okay skillon do pre-process
okay escal and
preprocessing standard
scalar okay
sorry and again like standard okay
ER yeah so standard scaler removes the
mean and scales each feature variable to
unit variance this operation is
performed feature wise in an independent
way everything is done let's see which
classify is best for prediction by
seeing their
accuracy so for that I will write
here let me do one
thing
yeah so like I will write
from
Elan do
emble sample yeah
import
random
Forest
classifier so I will write if
under class clf
classifier equals
to random
Forest
sorry my
bad so
RF uncore
clf do
fit
xcore
train comma Yore
train
in so I will write here
from
skar import
Matrix ycore prediction equals to RF
underscore
classifier dot
predict do
predict X _
test so here I will
print
accuracy of
random random
Forest classifier
is comma
Matrix
get dot
accuracy score
score then y underscore
prediction comma y underscore
test Yore
prediction so let's see the prediction
from the using random Forest classifier
and the accuracy a random for is a meta
estimator that employs averaging to
increase predicted accuracy and reduce
overfitting if Boost stab equals to true
the size of the subsample is determined
by the max sample argument otherwise
each is constructed using the entire
data set so here you can see the
accuracy is like
78% and here prediction you can see like
here one denotes that loan approv and
zero means loan will not approved so
accuracy is quite less so let's see for
another classification methods na
base so here I will write from
Escalon oh
put
goian NB na
base okay so NB
classifier equals
to goian
NB B underscore
classifier equals
to sorry do fit
strain comma y
train a not equals
to like goian Okay g is capital
sorry
yeah so let's predict the
value Yore
predict to
[Music]
NB scope
classifier dot
predict X
underscore
test
and
print
accuracy
of Nave
base
is comma like
Matrix dot
accuracy score
score y and underscore
prediction comma y underscore test so
accuracy of goian NB is 0.8 means
82% let's predict the value why
predict prediction like one is like loan
approved and zero is loan or not
approved so Nave base is a
classification algorithm for binary two
classes and multiclasses classification
problem it is called n based the
calculation of the probabilities for
each class are simplified to make their
calculation trackable so the accuracy is
82% and here prediction you can see one
denotes loan approved and zero means
loan will not approved so let's see for
another classification method like
decision tree
classifier for that I will write
here
from
Escalon do tree
import
decision
tree
classifier here I will write DT
underscore
classifier
to I will copy it from here
I will write here
dtore
clf equals
to so dot
fit xcore
train comma Yore
train
why is
small here I will see the
accuracy to
DT underscore
classifier dot
predict underscore for
test so here I will
print accuracy
of
dentry
is comma
Matrix
accuracy
underscore underscore predict
comma
Yore
test so here you can see the accuracy
70% so let me
predict so decision Tre the
non-parametric supervised learning
approach used for classification and
regression application it is organized
hierarchically as and has a note rout
branches internal nodes and leaf nodes
the so so the accuracy is 70% and here
prediction you can see one denotes the
loan approved and zero means loan will
not approved so let's do one more
classification we will do it from the
kabers using
kabers so here we will write
from
skan
ver
import K
neighbors
classifier K and
classifi we will
assign
this
so here we will write Kore
classifier dot
fit X under
train comma Yore
train okay SK
skar
sorry then
[Music]
again okay
Capital
here Capital
here
yeah it
yeah so here I will see the
accuracy
okay by prediction equals to
knore
classifier
dot
predict xcore
test
print
accuracy
of K neighbors
is at
do
accuracy score
score y underscore
prediction comma y underscore
test so let's see the accuracy so
accuracy is 79% and it is quite good so
the K neighbers the five closed
neighbors are sought for the k neighbers
classifier the classifier must be
splitly instructed to utilize ukan
distance to determine the proximity of
nearby points so the accuracy is
79% and here prediction you can see one
denotes the loan approved and zero means
loan will not
approv so you can
see Nave
base where's na base yeah so here you
can see we have na based classifier with
the best accuracy of 82% so we we can
use it for the loan approval prediction
system so in today's session we will
discuss what image classification is and
moving ahead we will discuss what CNN is
and at the end we will do a hands of lab
demo of image classification using
CNN so before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss what
image classification is and proceed
further for the same what is image
classification the process of
classifying an entire image is known as
as image
classification images are anticipated to
have just one class per image models for
image classification taken an image as
input and produce a prediction of the
class to which the image belongs so we
can utilize image classification models
when we are not interested in individual
instance of items with position
information or their
shape so let's see what is
CNN machine learning includes
convolutional neural networks also known
as convents or CNN it is a subset of the
several artificial neural network models
that are employed for diverse purpose
and data sets a CNN is a particular type
of network design for deep learning
algorithm that is utilized for task like
image recognition and pixel data
processing and so more okay although
there are different kinds of neural
network in deep learning CNN are
preferred neural architect for identify
and recognizing object therefore they
are rarely suited for computer vision
activities and application where
accurate object recognition is crucial
such as facial and self-driving
automobile system so moving ahead so
dear Learners if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
the completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course out details from the
description box below so now let's move
to our programming part of how to do
image classification using CNN if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more so first we we will open a command
prom to write a command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write
Jupiter
notebook press enter
so this is the landing page of jupyter
notebook so here you can select new
python
file so this is how the kernel look like
okay jupyter notebook kernels look
like so first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in like analyzing the data okay so in in
this file we will classify small images
of C if 10 data set from tens oflow data
set there are total 10 classes as shown
below so we will use CNN for the
classification purpose okay so here I
will write
import tensor
flow as
TF okay so from tensor
flow
dot
Kus
import data
sets comma
layers
models okay so we will
import numpy as
NP right and
import met plot
Li as PLT
right okay so here I will write P
plot as
PLT right so tensor flow this one this
so tensorflow is a free and op Source
machine learning and artificial
intelligence software Library it can be
used for variety of applications but it
focuses on mainly deep neural network
training and the inference purpose okay
got it and this numpy numai is a python
Library used for working with the arrays
it also has a function for working with
the domain of linear algebra and
matrices it is an open source project
and you can use it freely numai stand
for numerical
Python and this third one matplot lip
for Python and its numerical extension
numai matplot lip is a crossplatform
data visualization and graphical
charting package as a result it present
a strong open source substitute format
lab the apis application programming
interfaces format plot La allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI
applications got
it so let's run
this let me change
image
classification
using
CNN okay
so let's load the data set okay we will
load the data set from the
uh load data function so here I will
write
xcore
train comma Yore
train
okay and one for test
xcore test T comma Yore
test okay then equals to data
set dat sets dot we are using CER 10 C
far 10 far
10 do
load dot
underscore data
okay
it will load our data so let's load the
data so data is loaded let's see
X
score test dot
shape
okay
yeah so as you can see so we have th000
rows and and one Moree
xcore
train.
shap let me run
this so here you can
see like we see like training
data like training images are 50,000 and
the test images are 10,000 okay
so this is for testing this is for
training and so moving ahead we will see
for the
Y
train dot
shape
okay th000 and here we will see the
array so Yore
train
five okay let's on this first let me
give some space
yeah so here Yore train is a 2d array
like for our classification having 1D
array is a good enough so what we will
do we will convert this to now 1D array
this is 2D array we will convert into 1D
array okay
for
that will write here Yore
train equals to Yore
train dot
reshape minus one
comma okay then ycore
train and again semicolon
5 let's r this okay so now this is 1D
array so Yore
test = to Yore
test
dot d
shape minus
one here I will
write
classes
to there are some classes okay in the
data set like
airplane comma
automobile
B
comma cat
comma
here dog
Rog
Course
Truck okay so these are the some classes
like airplane automobile bird cat deer
so it will be help in classifying the
images so let's plot some images to see
like what they what they exactly are
okay so we will what we will do we will
create one
function for that let me write
here def plot underscore
sample okay then X comma y
comma
index
okay then I will write here plot. figure
PLT do
figure then figure size should
be comma 2 equals
to PLT do
show image show to I am show
X
index
PLT do X
label
classes y index
okay so let's see some samples of the
images so I will write a
plot underscore
sample uh xcore
train comma Yore
train okay comma let's see the fifth
image okay then
enter should be
Capital so as you can see this is a car
so it is showing automobile okay so
let's see once more
like plot underscore
sample xcore
train comma Yore
test comma we'll see the 10th
one okay it is not quite
visible so we'll go for the
okay okay I
am why it is showing wrong because I use
your test I have to use here train
instead of test then it will show I
think correct yeah you can see HS then
HS then what about 2011
image see you can
see so we will see once more
500 can see frog it's not quite
visible yeah so you can see
here the proper shape
okay so what we will do now we will
normalize the images to a number from 0
to one image has three channels like RGB
colors so and each value in the channel
can range from 0 to
255 hence to normalize in 0 to one range
we need to divide it by 255 okay
so now what we will do we will normalize
the
data so here what we'll do at xcore
train equals to X train divided by 255
and0
okay and same for
test to X
test divided
by
25.0 okay to range between 0 to
1 yeah we will build simple artificial
Nal Network for image classification
first okay so we will write here
Ann
alss to models dot
sequential okay then I will write here
layers
dot
plattin in put
underscore shape equals
to
32 comma 32 comma
okay then again layers dot
3,000 comma
activation to
rlu got
it then again for the, so I will what I
will do I will copy it and paste it here
okay so
th000 so uh let me add one more one more
layer dot
10s then we let 10 comma
activation to soft
Max
okay here I will okay let me give for
the better
visuals yeah
Ann NN do
compile
Optimizer okay to
SGD and
comma I will write here
loss equals
to
sparse
categorical cross entropy
okay so here I will write comma then
Matrix equals
to
accuracy
andn do
fit xcore
train comma Yore
train comma
EPO
okay so number I will give a boxal to
5 right so it will take time to
run it's
running yeah there is some
[Music]
issue
train box equals
to
five
what it is
saying in user code the file program
C engine
okay I will copy
it and P it
again R it
again okay now it's
working
okay so it will take time and then I
will get back to you
okay then
import numai you guys already know what
numai is
NP Yore
prediction to Ann do
predict
xcore
test okay then y
underscore prediction
underscore
classes equals
to NP
dot argu
Max
element for
element
in Yore
prediction
print
classification
for comma
_
report then y underscore test comma
ycore
prediction
underscore
classes okay so let me run
this
Capital yeah it will take less
time now we will create a graph
okay like X text is like we have
thousand images so CL graph will be like
messed up still let's see so I write
here
import
cbor as SNS
Okay Okay C
Bor yeah me give some
space here I will write PT dot
bigger size should
be 14a 7
okay then as in as we will create a heat
map for this and Yore
prediction not equals to
true then PLT doy
label this
truth PLT do X
label
then PLT do title should
be
Vision okay then PLT do
show let me run this
okay see why prediction has X
text it's still
running let's
wait so now let's make CNN model
okay to train our images so for that I
will write CNN equals
to models
dot
sequential
okay write C paste yeah so let me run
this so this is our CNN model from which
we will train our
images and CNN like
compile then
optimize
Optimizer equals to
ADM
okay okay
comma right here then loss equals
to sparse
categorical then
cross
entropy okay and comma I will write here
Matrix equals
to
accuracy run this
okay
Lo
yeah same goes for
[Music]
you
okay
loss I do I will rewrite
this okay now let's check CNN model for
the 10 epox
okay let's see the accuracies increasing
or
not
CNN let's go
train comma Yore
train
comma
box
let is
started it will take less time than the
previous one
okay
see
you want this whole code you can comment
down the same
okay after completing this I will get
back to
you oh it is almost done like 27 seconds
for the 10
epox till then let me write CNN do do
evaluate xcore test comma Yore test
okay
so with CNN the N5 epox accuracy was
around like 70% and which is a
significant improvement over Ann okay
Ann we have like just
49 okay and CNN are the best for image
classification and gives the superb
accuracy also competition is the much
less compared to simple Ann as Max
pooling reduces the image Dimension
while still uh preserving this uh
features okay so let me run
this take some
time till then I will write Yore
prediction equals to
CNN dot
predict then xcore
test
okay then I will write here Yore
prediction then colum
5 let me run
this so you can see the accuracy and all
the array
okay yeah so
let's classes equals to NP do ARG
Max
element
or element in y
prediction okay then
Yore
classes
then these are the number of classes
then yore
test is column
five these are the array so it's
converted into array then now let's see
the it is predicting Right image or
wrong image okay by not with the
training data here we predict from the
training data why training X train okay
now we will predict from the test data
so here I will write
plot andore
sample then xcore test comma Yore test
and you can write the random one so here
I will write
60 let's see so you can easily see here
this is H and it is predicting right
HS and let me okay
plot
sample then
xcore test comma Yore
test comma
100 okay PR
enter okay X is
capital yeah so you can see this is
De okay so our model is predicting the
correct image okay then what we like
let's see it is predicting the right
class or not okay we made the classes
like random
classes okay where are these these so
let's see it is predicting right or
wrong okay for that I have to write
classes Yore
classes it's like which number 60 okay
60 60 is not defined because like number
of
classes okay okay so there are 1 2 3 4 5
7 okay 0 to 9 I can
choose so here what I will
do I will take small one like I will
five okay this is
frog
okay this frog right
so I will take instead of 60 here I will
see
frog okay y class is not
defined Yore
classes is defined see okay there are 3
S yeah so as you can see frog this is
frog so our classes is defining right so
here I will write it again like
60 it was HSE and let me write here
60 you can see the right prediction
okay
so this is what how you can you do image
classification using CNN I hope you guys
must have understood this concept like
how to do image classification using CNN
you can ask in in the comment section
below if you have any queries if you
want to become an AI expert and gain
handsome salary packages look at the
wide range of e IML courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
now an year of experience is preferred
to enroll in these courses find the
course Link in the description box in
today's session we will go through what
is movie recommendation system after
that we will see how movie
recommendation system work moving
forward we will see filtering strategies
for movie recommendation system and at
the end we will see handson lab demo
like how to create movie recommendation
system using python in detail we already
have data set with us we will perform
different function and Implement a movie
recommendation system using python
before we move on to the programming
part let discuss what is movie
recommendation system actually is and
proceed further for the same
so renting CDs and DVDs reading local TV
listenings watching film strip
projectors or recordings all of this is
a thing of the past today all of the
world biggest film collection have been
digitized and moved to the online
streaming services like Netflix HBO or
YouTube this platform can now help us
with what is possibly the most difficult
task of all choosing a movie they have
been enhanced with AI powered
capabilities
well that is no longer a concern for you
it is finally time for machine learning
to put its skills on display in the
modern cinematic landscape to create
Advanced predictive system for True
movie expert data scientists are
prepared to investigate our behavioral
patterns and those of movies a movie
recommendation system also known as a
movie recommended system uses machine
learning to predict or filter user fil
preferences based on their prior
decision and action s it is an advanced
filtration system that anticipate the
consumer in question potential like
selection for a domain specific item a
movie so after seeing what is movie
recommendation system let's move forward
and see how movie recommendation system
actually works a movie recommendation
system fundamental idea is a pretty
straightforward every recommended system
primarily consists of two components
users and items user receive more
prediction from the system and the
actual movies are the products filtering
and predicting only the movies that are
matching user is most likely to wish to
seen the main objective of movie
recommendation system the user
information from the system database is
used by the ml algorithm for these
recommendation system based on
information from the past this data is
used to forecast the user in questions
behavior in the future data should be
handled by expert because because it is
so crucial to ml projects including the
movie recommendation
system after seeing how movie
recommendation system works let's see
some filtration strategies for movie
recommendation
system to assist user in finding the
most elevant films movie recommendation
system employ a variety of filtration
techniques and algorithm the contain
based filtering and the collaborative
filtering system subcategories of the ml
algorithm used for the movie
recommendations are the most well-liked
ones filtering based on content or
content based filtering a method of
filtering movies in a movie
recommendation system that makes
advantage of the items data this
information which is taken from the just
one user is quite important in this case
this technique uses an ml algorithm to
suggest movies that are comparable to
the user's past choices therefore the
information about the prior movie Cho
choices and likes just one person is
used to generate similarity in content
based
filtering and the second one is
collaborative filtering as the name
implies this filtering techniques is
based on the interaction between the
relevant person and the other user for
the best outcomes the system contrast
and compare these behaviors it combines
the film choices and uses patterns of
several people like there are two types
of collaborative filtering algorithm
the first one is collaborative filtering
based on users the goal is to find
patterns in Target users and other
database users like movie preferences
and the second one is collaborative item
based filtering the fundamental idea
behind this is to find comparable
products products like movies that
Target users rate or interact with after
seeing the filtering strategies for
movie recommendation system so here is
one question for you guys I will give
you one 1 minute for this you can
comment or you can give answer in chat
section so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or wrong I'm
repeating again so here is one question
for you guys I will give you one minute
exactly 1 minute for this you can
comment or you can give your answer in
chat section so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or
wrong so the question is which is the
best language for machine learning
programming
which is the best language for machine
learning the first one is Java the
second one is python the third one is R
language and the fourth one is
C++ so this is the question I'm
repeating again which is the best
language for machine
learning the option one is Java second
python our language and C++ so I'm
starting timer of 1 minute just type
your answers in comment section or in a
chat section do let me know your answers
please I want that everyone should
participate in this and make this live
session
interesting so I'm starting
timer oh your time starts
now please guys do let me know your
answers in chat section or in you can
comment
down
42 seconds to
go you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong 30 seconds
more which is the best language for
machine
learning you can give your answer chat
section or you can
comment so I can see if the answers
given by you are right or wrong guys
come on please I want that everyone
should participate in this and make this
live section
interesting come on guys 5 Second
more one yep time up so time is over we
will give reply those who gave correct
answer and those who didn't give correct
answer we will give you a reply with the
correct answer so now let's move to our
programming part to perform movie
Commendation system using
python so first we will open command
prom to write command to open jupyter
notebook so we will write
Jupiter notebook press
enter so this is the landing page of
Jupiter notebook and select here new new
python
file so this is how jupyter notebook UI
look likes so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in mathematical functioning
so so the first one is numpy import
numpy as NP so nump is a python Library
used for working with arrays it also has
a function for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numai stand for numerical
python so here NP NP is denoting numai
so we will import the next
Library import pandas
as PD
this should be space
yep so pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structures and operation for
manipulating numerical tables and time
series so so after importing libraries
we will move ahead and import data set
so for importing data set we have to
write like we have two data set with us
let me show you the data set we have two
data set with
us first one is
credits this
one and the second one is movies
one one movies one so don't worry you
can get these data set link in the
description box so let me
write
here
credits go data frame equals to pd.
read unor
CSV here you have to give your location
of the data
set
credits do CSV
the second one is
movies let's go data frame this is for
movie data frame pd.
read
SV so here you have to give the movie
location movie data set location
movies do
CSV okay okay everything seems good let
me run
this
yeah so
then here PD is for the pandas Library
read is used for reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you want to read
after this let's write code to see the
data set so we will write here credits
uncore
DF and we will run it so this is our so
this is our credit data set and next one
is movies
underscore so this is our movie data
set so this is how our board data set
look like so here you can see three
dots this one and here
also this one so so we are unable to see
our full data set like what if we want
like full 4803 rows so at that case we
can write
here PD do
set underscore
option
okay and here we will write
display do
maxcore call
colums
this and here we will write
none same for the row PD do
set
option
display do
Max underscore
rows
none
okay
none let's run
this so now if we will write credits
uncore
DF it is running
yeah so now you can see your full data
set like full credit data set with 4803
rows or 4802 rows because there is
this is starting from zero that's why so
what about movies data
set okay wa
running it is still running you can see
here so here you can see um full data
set set movie data set with 4802
rows or if you want to see only five top
rows so you can write here
credits DF do head so by this only five
top rows so from head you we can see our
five top rows and if we will use tail
instead of head we can see our last five
rows so here let me do with the movies
one DF
dot
tail yeah so here you can see 4798 row
4799 till
4802 so with tail we can see our last
five rows so moving forward let's merge
the credit data set to movie data set
because if we will combine them the
confusion will be less and at the end it
will be better for us so we will write
here
movies
underscore equals to movies
underscore data frame and
credits underscore
DF
on it okay T is a small I guess yeah
perfect
title so let me do something something
like
this
okay it is saying data frame object is
not
callable
editore
DF
movies
okay why because we haven't wrote merge
here now it will
work yeah perfect it's working so data
is merged let's see the number of rows
and column using shave function so now
we have only one so
moviescore DF do
shape okay let's run it 4809 and 23 23
but if you see here like in movies data
set so in movies data set here here yeah
here there are 20 and in here we are
four columns in Credit Data
set
so like so you will be thinking that's
why not 24 why only 23 columns that is
why on title you can see here on title
the titles in both titles are same you
can see
here both titles are
same in
both okay let me show you like this okay
avar Pirates of the Caribbean Spectra
and so on here you can see AAR PIR of
the caran Spectra and so
on so that is why on title written while
merging so title are same so moving
forward let's see our mer data set so we
will write only
moviescore datf frame.
head
yeah so our data is merged you can see
the last C cre movie ID yeah you can see
here movie ID title are the same they
mer C crew okay
guys let me give some
more for the better view
yeah so you can see all Columns of
credit data set are added to movies one
so moving forward let's see another
function like
moviescore DF do
info so by this yes you can see so by
this the data frame information is
printed via the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use rage
index and the number of cells in each
columns like non-null values note that
info method does indeed print the
information so here you can see the all
the information is
printed
okay like columns name and the all null
values count and data types to like this
int object
INT in which we are working most so
after this let's move forward and select
some main column in which you are
working most so we will write
moviescore DF equals to
moviescore
DF comma and another one is o
overview
why okay here we have to like this yeah
so here we have to write
joner joner is complete and we will work
on what keywords keywords are the
main keywords okay keywords then to
cost then we
will we will do recommendation with the
crew as
well
okay by running this let me see our data
again with seven okay okay there is one
error okay this is movie movie idea Jon
yeah not in index okay got it got it why
not joner
it's jonuts I
guess what it is it's jonuts
that's
why it's joners
okay yeah so let's see our data again
with seven columns so I will write so I
will write here moviescore
DF do
head
here so you can see only our we have
like movies ID same title overview
joners keywords cast and crew
only so here you you can see the
selected columns okay so let's move
forward and once again let's see the
info again like
moviescore DF
dot info is come with selected columns
and let's move forward and see how many
missing values are present in particular
column so like the columns is full we
can see here but we don't know about
that 4,803 values are filled or not so
what we will do it we will see how many
missing values are present there so here
we will write like
movies underscore DF do is
null
do
sum not like
this yeah
perfect so the function data frame is
null this one is null do sum do sum
Returns the number of missing values in
the data set so here you can see
overview have three missing values so
what we can do is we can write here W
moviescore
DF
dot drop
na
Place equals to
True
okay we will run it it's sayings okay
document Dr
A
so true okay
fine doore drop and yeah it will not
create an issue so if you set in place
equals to true the drop any method will
modify your data frame directly that
means that if you set in place equals to
true the drop any will drop all missing
values from your original data set let's
move forward and see
movies
underscore DF
dot
duplicated so the duplicate method
returns a series with true or false
values that describe which rows in the
data frame are duplicated or not use the
subset parameter to specify if any
column should not be considered when
looking for duplicates
so here let me run this first so here we
we are getting zero why zero so if you
are like thinking there is no true or
false return return so if you write it
without sum like if I will write it
without
some okay let me copy from here yeah and
I will run this so here you can see
false false false in whole data set so
sum will combine them and return you a
value at the end zero represent false
itself so we need to not need this so we
will write something else so moving
forward let me write first
movies _ DF do I
location
0 dot
Jers let me run
this so the iog fun function this one
iog function first let me do something
like this it will go up okay huh okay so
from iog function in Python is defined
in the pandas module that helps us to
select a specific row or column from the
data set using the iog method in Python
we can easily retrieve any particular
value from a row or column by using
index value so here zero position line
is
coming
which is here you can
see so name action like name action name
Adventure name fantasy this s
fiction this one science fiction yeah so
this is because I'm giving here Jer that
is why you can see here see ID 28 name
action name something something
something like that okay so let's import
something called ASG abstract syntax
tree so this is one of the major Library
import
a let me run this import is a class
defined is the EST module that is used
to express the import statement in
python in the form of abstract syntax
tree so so an abstract syntax tree or
just syntax tree is a tree
representation of the of the abstract
syntactic structure of text written in a
formal language each node of the tree
denotes a construct occurring in the
text so let's convert some like literal
to object and append them so here I will
write
def
convert obj
object like
L equals
to blank
array for I in in STD
do bit
May Which
object okay like l
doen
return here we are converting is like
here is a convert is a function and L is
a array to append by using follow Loop
we can append them to name so let me
write code then I will explain like what
is happening so let me write full code
so
movies _
DF like
doners okay goes to
movies
jut and then dot
apply
but so then movies under score
DF then I will write
keywords to
moviescore
DF
keywords
Li
DF
dot so if we will see our old data set
in that like we will see old data set in
that joner and this keyword this keyword
apps ID name and so on like ID that name
like this type of things so it will
create a mess in retrieving them so by
using as Library we just convert them to
the normal one like title so got it guys
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code or question just put
as in commment our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution I'm
preting again I hope you guys understand
till here if you have any type of
questions regarding any code or
something so just put as in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution so moving forward let's
convert C two and like same as previous
way like like this only so what we will
do here we will write def
convert here I'm
using so l equals
to counter equals
to0
St do
literal if
counter
does
not equals to 3 then l
dot l
dot do append okay then here I have to
write I to
name
okay
cter
equals to 1 if you want to write like
counter equals to counter + 1 it is like
both the
same
else
like
turn
l so let me run this let me run
this
okay so after this small code we have to
assign the values like we are doing it
for cast now so
[Music]
movies okay
moviescore DF then
cast to
moviescore
DF
past
convert everything seems
good so let's see the changes are
visible or not so we will write here
moviescore DF do
head you can ignore this like this is
nothing so here you can see cast is also
same like keyword and joner so like
let's do for the cre to so like we are
converting you can say in a structured
way so let's do for the cre one to so
let me put
some
yeah so here we will add Dev like
fetch f is nothing like a function name
fet Direct
obj
okay colon l equals
to for I
NST do
literal
obj
if
I like
job equals to like we can say
director so then L do
append L do
[Music]
append app to the same
name go
J okay capital
[Music]
L so we have to again write that
movies equals to
movies
in
crew
apply just remember F director is a
function name let's see
changes so here I have to write movies
then press enter so yeah crew is all set
so changes are visible and data is
looking good so what we like if I want
to see the first movie ofar overview
this like this dot dot dot dot so I have
to write here like
movies
overview Overview at Jero
place so yeah so this is a full overview
of AAR movie like let me read for this
in this 2
Century a paric marine is dispatched and
blah blah blah blah and
civilization so moving forward that what
we want to recommend movie in the basis
of overview genre keyword cast so for
that we need a separate separate words
like in the then 22nd century
along so if you will see in other
columns all the words are separated but
like here if you will see all the words
are separated like action is separated
Adventure is separated fantasy separated
so there is a long sentence in this this
one in the overview one this is a long
sentence so it's difficult to recommend
from this so what we are going to do is
well we will separate them like like
other columns so here we will
write
movies
overview was to movies
then
overview and Dot
apply apply my bad
sorry then
Lambda colon x dot split
yeah ER so let's see the results so
movies yeah you can see in the set one
so now you can see all the words are
separated by comma so now it will easy
to match overview to recommend a
particular movie so moving forward so
what we are going to do is if there is a
two word and space between there so we
we are going to remove that space so
here you can see science fiction are
separate separate okay so we are going
to like remove this one this is space so
let's write code for that so here I will
write
like overview is already done so we will
do not do for that so let's write code
for the rest
columns so here I have to
write
movies like
Jers to
movies then again
juts not
apply
Lambda
x i dot
replace
space to no
space uh it seems
good then I have to write for everywhere
so for I in
X it's 4 I in x 4 I in
X movies Jers equals to movie Jers do
apply Lambda X i. replace this to this
for seems Cod so let's copy paste this
see one for keywords and one for cost
and
crew
C
first then
you test is same so let me run
this okay no error seems good so let's
see the change changes so
movies
yeah so now you can see the science
fiction space is gone like here is
science fiction space is there now
science fiction space is
gone so like uh okay let's move forward
and create one new column name as tag
and put all the column data in a
particular column okay let me do first
yeah let me write
movies is a column of column name goes
to
movies then first we will put
overview Plus
movies and
geners
and
movies and what we have to give uh
keywords
keywords then again
movies
then
p
me run
this okay so let's see the data frame uh
movies okay still coming so like there
is one problem I guess yeah no no no so
here you can see all the data is merged
in a under tag column yes you can see
like in the second sensory blah blah
blah
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code or anything just put
as in comment or our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution okay so
I'm repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
or like any question just put as in
command our team will shortly provide
you the correct
solution so from here let's create a a
new data
frame
okay so let me create new data frame
because now we don't need this overview
C crew joner like columns like this we
have already merged into a one one
column like tag column so we will write
here
new DF equals to
movies
okay so like movies we need more movie
ID new data frame we need movie ID comma
we need
Title and we have everything in tag
column TX column so we need TX
column okay let's run this let's see our
new data
frame yeah so this is how our new data
look lies with only three columns like
movie ID title and text so here you you
can see array brackets like this this
aray
brackets so we are going to uh remove
them so we will do what we will write
here we will write
new data
frame that
intax equals to
new data
frame
TX do
apply
Lambda
X then I will give
space dot
join same good everything is okay okay
fine
yeah so let's see the results
so we will write here newcore data
frame
so you can see the brackets are removed
now let's see the data which is present
in the zeroth index in tag column like
this dot dot dot in the okay for that we
have to write
here uh a
new data
frame
TX we did it before like for the
overviewer so here we have to yeah so
this is the whole data in the first
like first index zeroth index so some
part of the overview like from
civilization and some are you can see
this action adventage fantasy science
fiction these are some like
Jers
and uh like here you can see like these
are some Crews
members
and yeah like Sam warington like there
are some cast crew okay so like moving
forward like what we are going to do is
just make them in lower case for the
better prediction like something in
capital and something like smaller so
let's make it to lower case so newcore
DF
TX equals to
newcore
DF
tax
do
apply scum X do
lower
okay so don't worry about this
error let's see the result uh newcore DF
Dot
yeah now all the data present at TAG
column is in a small case or you can say
lower case moving forward let's do some
feature extraction using count
vectorizer so let let me write first
from
skar dot
feature
extraction feature extraction okay cool
do
text import
count
factorer CV equals
to
count
Riser
underscore
features
features equals to like
5,000
ofp
words equals to
English and this yeah so count
vectorizer okay there is
a I cannot import C vectorizer from
eSalon from
user
okay okay sorry sorry my bad here V is
capital okay guys so he V is capital
yeah so no error so count vectorizer is
a great tool provided by the psychic
learn library in Python it is used to
transform a given text into a vector on
the basis of the frequency count of each
word that occurs in the entire text
so let me write something CV
dot pit
uncore
transform
f x like dot 2
aray shape
okay so the fit method like learns a
vocabulary dictionary of all tokens in
the Raw documents that is it creates a
dictionary of tokens by default the
tokens are words separated by spaces and
like punctuations so that Maps each
single token to a position in the output
Matrix so here CV is a like here CV is a
counter vectorizer so let's convert into
Vector to array so for this we have to
write V
vectors vectors equals to CV do
fit okay then
transform
X
in so here we have to write Dot
to
array yeah then we have to write
Vector it's
vectors yeah you can see Vector 2 array
all the
zeros Okay so so moving forward let's
get the feature Name by
writing okay so we will write
here Lean l cv.
get
Feature
names feature names okay then
bracket yeah
so okay we have like 500 feature names
so I'm repeating I'm saying again like I
hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code whatever it is so
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
okay guys like any code or you are not
understand anything just put as in
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution so let's import
some major Library which is import
nltk so what is nltk the natural
language toolkit nltk is a platform used
for building python programs that work
with human language for applying in
statical natural language processing NLP
it contain text processing libraries for
tokenization parsing classification
stemming taging and semantic
reasoning so moving forward like from
let me write first from n
nltk dot
stem dot
Porter
import
pter yes equals
to
order
timing is a process for reducing a word
to its word stem that suffix and prefix
are to the roots of words known as Alma
stemming is important in natural
language understanding nlu and natural
language processing
NLP so here like I have to write so here
I will write def stem
to
text y equals
to for I in text.
Split y dot
aen dot stem
done
join
y so let's apply timing to a tag column
so here we will write new
DF Tex
equals to
newf
tag do
apply so let's import cosine similarity
from skarn so we will write from SK
lar dot
matrices do pairwise
import
cosine underscore
similarity okay it seem good from escal
and
matrices Matrix sorry Matrix dot
pairwise it
is PIR
wise pairwise import cosine similarity
okay let's run this no error so cosine
similarity May measures the similarity
between two factors I repeat cosine
similarity measures the similarity
between two vectors of an inner product
space it is measured by the cosine of
the angle between two vectors and
determines whether two vectors are
pointing in roughly the same direction
it is often used to measure document
similarity in text analysis so here we
will
write
cosine underscore
similarity
vectors so these all are the vector
present let's see the cosine similarity
Vector column and row using space so
here I will write
cosine go
[Music]
similarity
vectors do
shape it's still running you can see
here yeah so 4806 rows and 4806 columns
are there let's assign variable
similarity to this okay so let's
similarity we'll write like this to
cosine similarity
underscore
here why I did this because we don't
have to write always this long sentence
a long keyword you can
say moving forward let's see First
Column like we will add similarity
yeah so this is our first column uh so
let's see the rows only so we will write
here
Clarity
Z
dot
shape
okay 4806 okay so let's move forward and
let's create some like sorted list so
for that sort
it
okay
T
enumerate spelling is
fine okay one more like seei
similarity
zero there I have to write
reverse equals to
True comma key = to
Lambda colon X not capital x
x have to write
one one colon
six seems good yeah so the enumerate
function in Python converts a data
collection object into an enumerate
object enumerate returns an object that
contains a counter as a key for each
value with an object making item within
a collection easier to access so finally
let's create the recommend function to
check the movie recommendation
system
okay
so so let's write here
DF
recommend
to
new
DF and the
TF
title equals to equals to
movie
x
z
tenses to
similarity and
movie okay so
movies list equals to
sorted
list
numerate r
rate
distances
reverse to
True
keyword sorry key only key equals to
Lambda colon X
six or I in
movies
list
F do
iock
I
zero Z do title we because we need Title
only so yeah it seems good
okay so finally that like time is
G
so finally the time has come to check
the recommendation of your favorite
movies so you can commment in the chat
section so I can check so let me write
first
recommend recommend for movie
Avatar okay so here you can see the
recommendation system is working fine so
Titan a. small soldier Independence Day
are the recommendation for the movie
ofar so let me me check for the another
one
recommend like
for one of my favorite movie Iron
Man so here you can see Iron Man 2 Iron
Man 3 Avengers agage of Ultron Captain
America and the Avengers are the
recommendations for the movie Iron Man
so let me check for the one more
recommend
liar
liar T's Going on 30 and the last one is
last one I want to check is Captain
America Civil
War let me copy from here
only yeah you can see the Captain
America the First Avenger the vter
soldier Iron Man 3 Age of Ultron The
Avengers so I hope you guys understand
till here if you have any questions or
any query regarding any code or question
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
if you want to become an AI expert and
gain handsome salary packages look at
the wide range of eiml courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
now an year of experience is preferred
to enroll in these courses find the
course Link in the description box so in
today's session we will discuss what
time series forecasting is after that a
hands off lab demo of how you can do
time series forecasting using machine
learning we will perform different
function and different python libraries
for analyzing the data before we move on
to the programming parts let's discuss
time series forecasting and proceed
further for the
same what is time series
forecasting making scientific projection
based on the data with historical time
stamps is known as time series
forecasting it entails creating model
through historical study using them to
draw conclusion and guide strategic
decision making in the
future the fact that the future result
is wholly unknown at the time of the
task and can only be anticipated through
analysis and evidence-based priors is an
essential distinction in forecasting
give yourself a chance to Simply Lear
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in- depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box
below so here is one question for you
guys I will give you exactly one minute
for this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the anwers given by you are right
or wrong okay so the question is which
type of programming does python support
I'm repeating again which type of
programming does python support option A
objectoriented programming option b
structured programming option C
functional programming and option D all
of the
above so let us know in your answer in
the chat section or in the comment
section so I'm starting a timer of 1
minute just type your answer in the
comment section or in the chat section
do let me know your answers please so
I'm starting the timer of 1
minute which type of programming does
python support object oriented structure
programming functional or all of the
above do let me know your answers
please you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answers given by you are
right or
wrong which type of programming does
python support objectoriented structured
functional or all of the
above 30 seconds
meaning
which type of programming does python
support objectoriented structured
function or all of the above let us know
your answers in the chat section or in
the comment section
below 10 seconds more which type of
programming does python support 5
Seconds
more so the allerted time is over we
will give a reply to those who gave the
correct answer and for those who didn't
give the correct answer we will give you
reply with the correct answer okay now
let's move to our programming
part so we will open command prom to
write a command to open jupyter notebook
so here I will write Jupiter
notebook press okay
Jupiter notebook press
enter you take
time
open so this is the landing page of
jupyter notbook and here I will select
new python kernel
file so this is how Jupiter Kel look
lies so
here what we will do we will import some
major libraries of python which will
help us in analyzing the data
okay import
numai as
NP okay then
import
pandas
SD then
import
cbor as
SNS the fourth one is
from M plot
Li
Port pip
plot as
PLT okay then we will import some model
libraries so here I will write
from
stats
models
TSA do
API import
exponential
muting and comma
then
simple XP
smoothing then one more
old we will write here import sorry
from Escalon dot
linear underscore
model
import
linear
ression
okay then
import
warnings
warnings then we will write here
dot filter
warnings it should be
ignore
yes there will be no error it's still
loading yeah so numpy numai is a python
Library used for working with arrays it
also has a function for working with the
domain of linear algebra and matrices it
is an open source project and you can
use it freely numai stand for numerical
python second is Panda pandas is a
software Library written for the Python
programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operations
for manipulating numerical data and time
cities then cbone an open- Source python
Library based on M plot lab is called
cbon it is utilized for data exploration
and data
visualization with data frames and the
Panda's labor cbone function with
ease M plot lip for Python and its
numerical extension numai met PL Li is a
crossplatform data visualization and
graphical charting package
as a result it presents a strong open
source substitute for
MPL the apis for matplot Li allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI
applications linear regression the
machine learning method regression built
on linear supervised learning analysis
regression is done regression creates a
value for the aim prediction using
independent variables as
inputs it main goal is to investigate
the relationship between factors and
forecasting exponential
smoothing the exponential Windows
function is a general method for
smoothing time series data known as
exponential smoothing it contrasts to
the ordinary moving average which
weights previous data
quality exponential function use weights
that decrease exponentially with time
and there is one more simple exponential
smothing the simple exponential
smoothing classes use Simple exponential
smoothing models to give very simple
time series
analysis a weight average of the most
recent value and the preceding smooth
value constitute the predicted value the
contribution of older value degrade
exponentially as a result of the
smoothing
parameter okay so after importing
libraries let's import data set for this
I will write here
DF or you can write data frame PD do
feore
CSV here I will write
monthly underscore
CSV do
CSV okay this is my file name you can
download this file from the description
box
below and for seeing the data I will
write here DF dot
head and then press enter
yeah so here PD is for Panda's Library
read is used for reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you are using okay or
which you want to
read and if you want to see the top five
rows of your data set you can use head
and if you want to see the last five
rows of your data set you can use tail
instead of head okay this one you can
write here
tail so moving forward let's see how
many rows and columns are present in our
data set for that I have to write DF do
shape okay then press enter okay it will
give error why
because this
yeah so here you can see 847 rows and
two columns date and price
only so moving forward let's do some Eda
explorat data analysis okay for that I
have to write here
print
data date
range
of of gold
prices available
from
then here I have to give C brackets then
DF dot location
Lo then
colon
comma
date okay D is capital here so I have to
write
date then from location
zero to
again same thing DF
dot
LC
date to the length
of
BF minus
one
oh everything seems good yeah then press
enter
okay we have date range of gold prices
available from this 1950 to 2020 okay in
our data
set then here I will write
date equals to PD
Dot
date
range start
from
slash1 SL
comma and equals
to 8 slash
1/2020
comma
frequency equals to
median okay
then then here I will write
date then press enter
yeah so here you can see T time index
okay from starting till end these dot
dots and here I will
write DF
month equals
to
date we have dot
drop
State comma XIs is
one comma in
place to true
T should be
capital okay then DF equals to
DF do
set
index and
month and
DF dot
head press enter
so instead of this
date we have adjusted this
month okay for particular
value so moving forward let's see the
graph different different graphs okay DF
do
plot then figure set should
be
to 20 comma 8
then
plot dot
title
is like
gold
prices
monthly
since
1950 and
onwards okay title should be this then X
level should be PLT do X
label will be
months then PLT do y
labels should be
price then I will write here PLT dot
grid okay press
enter okay title spelling my bad tle
okay then press
enter oh y label it is
sorry
yeah here you can see gold prices
monthly since 1950 and on
onwards okay till from 1950 and from
till 2020 okay this is the
price then moving forward let's see
another graph so I will write here for
that round DF dot
describe comma
3 and here you can see the count
variable and the average is
46.57 standard deviation that minimum
price value is this 20% this and the
maximum value is this okay
so so the average gold price in last 70
years is this 4 16.55 7
okay only 25% of the time the gold price
is above
the highest gold price ever touched this
this one 1840
807 so we will do visual analysis so
here I will
write ax equals to PLT do
subplots SUB
plots okay then and figure
size to
25 comma
art okay then SNS dot box
plot is
xals
to DF do
index do ear comma y equals to DF do
values colum comma
0 comma ax = to a
x
okay then same PLT do
title gold
price
monthly
1950 same graph will come but in the
different format
okay let me remove
this then PLT do dot X
label must be
here LT dot y
lbel
PR and PLT
dot
xticks will be
rotation
to okay I will give rotation
90 PLT do
grid can write here instead of grid I
can write here directly show so grid is
this format this box format okay so
press
enter it's loading yeah so here you can
see from 1950 every year is here till
2020 so how the gold prices are
decreasing and increasing
okay let's see the another
graph I will write here
from that'ss
models
models dot
Graphics Dot
TSA
plots
Port month
plot okay then I will write here figure
comma ax equals to then PLT
dot
subplots figer
size
equals to 22 comma
8 okay then month
plot DF comma y
Lael to
gold
price okay comma then a x equals to
ax I will give the title PLT
dot
title I will copy from
here
okay and PLT do X
label
month and PLT dot y
Lael the
price PLT dot
grit so here you can see gold prices
monthly since
1950 like for every month like January
February March April so on till December
okay we will cover one more
graph okay and many many more
graphs
so we
will go with the next
graph for that I will WR
here let's go
comma
ax equals to PLT do
subplots then figure
size equals
to 22 comma
8 then same
SNS Dot
boxplot x equals
to DF do
index do month
name okay then y =
to DF do
values comma Z
0 comma ax = to
ax okay then PLT do
title we put same title so I can copy
from it
here let's copy from here and paste it
here
okay and pl
dot X
label and PLT do y
label
price and PLT do
grit
okay.
show this time let's let's not use
grid
Okay okay something PDS month
name yes you can
see for every month this is another type
of
graph okay box plot graph so why we are
creating so much graphs because we are
doing Eda exploratory data analysis in
this we have to see the multiple
different and different different types
of
graph okay so moving forward let's see
average gold price per year like Trend
since
1950 so for that I have to write here
DF go
yearly let go sum
to DF do
resample
sample
then
a dot
mean DF
uncore underscore
sum do plot
dot PLT dot
title and here I will write
average gold
price
yearly
since
1950 or you can write onwards from
onwards 1950 so so here I will write PLT
do X
Lael
here and PLT do y
label
ice okay then PLT do grid this time
we'll use
grid
so here you can see the average gold
price yearly since 1950 okay this is the
chart till 2020 like sometimes up
sometimes down
okay and we will see now like average
gold price per quarter like trends like
since
1950 so here I will write DF
dot not DOT DF dot
quarterly
okay underscore sum equals
to DF do
resample water
[Music]
Q dot
mean
okay
okay move this
then DF
underscore
quarterly score
sum do
plot then the same PLT do
title from
here
here I will write average good price
waterly
quarterly okay since
1950 then PLT dot X
label label is now here
quarter
PLT do y
lbel is
price okay now PLT do
show this
time
okay F
quarterly okay
quarterly yeah
here you can see the price prediction
okay let me set to the grid
only it's not
this visuals are not good so
crit yeah so here you can see the
quarterly prices
prediction okay average gold price
quarterly
prediction so like moving
forward we will see now average gold
price per decade like per 10 years okay
so from 1950 only so here I will write
DF underscore
DEET underscore
sum to DF do
resample every 10 year okay 10
year
do
mean we are writing mean because we are
like putting out
average okay so DF underscore
DEET underscore
sum do
plot PLT dot
title average
goal
price per
decade
since
okay since 1950 yeah
perfect so here I will get PLT dot X
label then decade decade is of like
every 10 year p LT do y
label PLT do
grid yeah so here you can see the
average gold price per decade like from
1950 to 1960 like this straight then
again straight then up then sometimes
down then up and down okay every 10
years you can see 1992 20 2010 and
2020 so moving forward let's do like
analysis in coefficient of variation the
coefficient of variation CV is a
statical measure of the relative
disperson of data points in a data
series around the
mean and in finance the coefficient of
variation allows investor to determine
how much verality or risk is assumed in
comparison of the amount like amount to
the return expected from investors
okay the lower the ratio of the standard
deviation to mean return the better risk
return
tradeoff okay let's like let us look now
the CV values for each year in gold
prices so CV means coefficient of
variation in prices okay so here I will
write DF underscore 1 equals to DF dot
Group
by
have.
index
do do
mean
name do
columns equals
to iate
price
and
mean okay then again
df1 equals to
df1 dot
range or what we can do instead of range
we can write
merch DF do group
by go DF Dot
Tex dot
EO standard
deviation theen
name
columns equals
to
PR standard deviation
comma
left
index to
true then comma right
index Al so
true
okay
and here DF uncore
SC
to efcore
1 standard
deviation slash DF uncore
to
100 like
dot round figure should be like two
after decimal how much like numbers you
want to
see then
df1 do
headit
enter yeah so here you can see for every
year I have mean standard
deviation and this coefficient of
variation okay for every
year
so like moving forward let's see the
average gold price per year
again so for that
figure
underscore
figer dot comma
ax equals to
PLT dot
subplot bigger
size 15
comma 10
yeah then I will write here
df1
is like
coore
do
plot elt do
title average gold price
yearly
since
1950 okay then PLT do X
LEL is
here or PLT
do y
label y
label
coefficient of variation I'm writing
CV in
percent okay then PLT do
show get DF uncore invalid syntax
okay what C
Capital do
plot okay so DF uncore 1 DF uncore
here
syntax
okay so here you can see average gold
price since
okay this is like percentage CV in
percent
okay like
good you can say the
chart so the CV value reached its
highest in 1978 like somewhere here like
1978 okay like near to 25% which could
have made the asset as a highly risky
but in 2020 the CV value is closer to 5%
which makes the asset variable by good
investment okay so now what we will do
we will do time series
forecasting okay we will train model we
will build model different different
model we will train and test split to
build time series forecasting model so
for that let me do like this
first
yeah so here I will write
train equals to DF
DF do
index dot per
year okay equals to
2015 and for the testing we will write
DF DF do
index.
2015 okay for training we are taking
till 2015 for and for the testing we are
taking till 2020 from 2015
okay then I will write here how many
columns present in train or test so for
that I will write print
train do
shape and print
test. shift press enter 792 rows and one
column in train training for training
the model and 55 to test the model
okay so now let's see the training data
and testing data so
train like square brackets
so
price do
plot then figure
size =
to 13 comma
and font size should
be to
ize Dot
Plot bigger
size bigger
size let me
give same 13 comma
5 and font size should
be six
okay then PLT dot let me add
grid PLT do
gr then
PLT dot
Legend
Training
data
comma test
data okay okay then
PLT show I will tell you what the legend
is
okay so here you can see the training
data in blue and the testing data okay
this is known as the legend this this
portion and yeah so here you can see
month
wise okay till 2020
and from
1950 right these are the
prices and this is the chart so moving
forward let's do model formation now
okay we will do two models
linear linear regression and the Nave
base one okay so first we are first we
will go
from linear regression for that I will
write train underscore time
= to I +
for I in
range test underscore time equals
to I +
length like
train one for I
in range then length should be
test okay so for
length training
time comma length should be
tested
prenter okay this is the training and
this for the testing 792 rows and here
55 rows
interesting
so
lror LR means linear regression let me
make it
capital R equals to make a
copy
L
rore test equals to test
copy dot
copy then
LR
okay
so
LR
R
train
time to train
time okay and
LR underscore
test
time equals to test
time okay underscore
is
yeah so here I will write LR equals to
linear
regression do f F to the
model LR
train and for the
time
lot
CL underscore
Train
Price
values linear regression is not defined
okay my bad L should be Capital
yeah so now see the graph so test
underscore
prediction let's go model
one equals to l
dot
predict
lore
test
time lore
C was to
test underscore
predictions score
model
one okay let's create the graph
figure figure size should
be so 14 comma
PLT do
plot
R price
comma label should
be
train okay then
plot PLT do
plot
test
device label equals to
test PLT do
plot then LR train or
tests
forast
label equals to regression on time okay
regression on
time then again PLT do
Legend
l equals
to
best PLT do
git that's
enter
okay here I have to
write
loading one more
error
price
price okay
is the
price so here you can see regression on
time test data is this green one and
this training data and the testing
data okay let's find the map now so for
this we'll write here
DF m
n comma
prediction then
return
round we do
mean
ABS
actual
setion
jeel
by
100 comma
okay for to give the
yeah so for for getting map you have to
write here map
underscore
model let's go test equals to
map
test
price dot
values
comma test
underscore
section model
one
okay then
print
is person
3 Dot 3
F then here after
percent AP
model 1 underscore
test
comma
percentage press
enter
next
okay is not
defined m
test model one
test May
T value use the
test
FS model
one okay here a is
small
so map here you can see
29.760426
so you are bit confused like what is map
map is a measure of prediction of
accuracy of a forecasting method in a
statical model OKAY is a measure of
prediction accuracy of forecasting
method in statical
method and
now this
equals to PD
do data
frame test
map in
percent
underscore model
one comma
index equals
to
regression on
time okay then I will print the
results okay D should be
Capital pandas has no attribute data
frame
OKAY model one is not
defined that's go
t Val perhaps you got to forget a
comma
colon model one
okay here you can see the test map
regression on time so let's do it with
the name now we have to perform the same
pattern so what I will do what I I will
write the code and get back to you okay
so I'm done with the code uh so here you
can see I have same pattern train and
test copy and this is the name forecast
on the test data so this is the line and
this is the training and this orange one
is
testing the same we have got M like
19.38
Okay so and regression is
this the name model so what we will do
we will create now final model of HS
okay and we will forecast final
forecasting we'll
do
for that I have to write
final model equals to
exponential
smoothing okay DF
comma
and equals
to
netive comma
seasonal purum
additive comma
fit
smoothing level to
0.4
smoothing
Trend to
0.3 comma
smoothing
seasonal = to
0.6 okay press
enter exponential
exponential
so
map final andore model is equals
to
map like
DF
price dot
values comma
final let's go
model
dot fitted
values then
print
M comma
map
score final underscore
model okay
so map is 17.24 which is quite good for
the final
model
okay so getting the prediction for the
same number of time stamps at the
present time in the test data so I will
write here
predictions equals to
final underscore model dot
forecast
steps equals to length.
test
center now we will compute 95 5% of
confidence interval for the predicted
value so TF equals to PD dot data
frames
then
low
CI
prediction
1.96
into NP do standard deviation of
final mod
dot
one
okay and
comma right here
prediction okay then upper
CI
action plus
1.96
into dot standard
deviation the same final model
so
one okay then
prediction uncore DF dot
head okay so this is lower CI prediction
and the upper CI okay how much it will
forecast or
now at the end at the final State what
we will do we will plot a graph okay
forecast graph along with the confidence
band So for that X is equals to DF do
plot
label equals
to
actual comma figure
size
16 comma 9
addtion
DF dot
dot ax equals
to
this from a
label underscore
DF it's lower CI
what I will do inste of
this label equals
to
forast comma
Alpha = to
0.5 okay
this do
fill
between
Shore
DF dot
index comma prediction underscore
DF lore
CI comma prediction underscore
DF this
CI
then
coloral
to
M
comma
Alpha equals
to5
okay then
XIs do
set score X
label year
month
AIS do
set y
lab PLT do
Legend should be
locational to
best then PLT dot
grid PLT Dosh
show okay this is PLT only then press
enter okay 16 comma 9 positional
argument follows keyword
argument right
15 oh
okay okay I have to give
you upper
CI upper
C so here you can see our final model
forecasting so till 2020 it is showing
like normal and after that till
2030 okay this will be the forecast as
per the
data
okay so here you can
see you can see we have the map is
17.24 okay then here I did the
prediction for the testing data and here
I created the data
frames these are the data frames lower
CI prediction and upper C and then I
have
created the and then I have created the
final graph of the forecasting if you
want to become an AI expert and gain
handsome salary packages look at the
wide range of e IML costes by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
now an year of experience is preferred
to enroll in these courses find the
course Link in the description box in
today's session we will go through what
is text to speech converter after that
we will create text to speech converter
application using python this we will
create this
one we will perform different functions
and create amazing UI for application
using different python libraries before
we move on to the programming part let
discuss what is text to speech converter
and proceed further for the same text to
speech is an API cloud service that
enables you to turn written text into
real sounding audio in a range of
languages and voices by connecting with
people in their own language you can
give your business a voice and enhance
customer experience and engagement
increasingly accessibility of users of
diverse abilities offering audio
alternatives to prevent driving while
disected or automating customer service
interaction to reduce hold
items let's move to our programming part
to create a text to speech converter
application using
python so first we will open command
prompt to write command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write
Jupiter notebook to open jupyter
notebook press
enter yeah so this is the landing page
of jupyter notebook and select open new
python
file so this is how the jupyter UI looks
like so at first we will import some
major libraries of python which will
help us in creating UI and to convert
text to speech so the first one is
import sorry
import
TK
enter as
TK so TK enter is also known as TK
interface the default python interface
for TCL TK GUI toolkit is the TK inter
package or tiker
interface majority of unique System
including Mac OS as well as Windows
machine support TK and TK inter TK inter
which is part of all common python dist
distribution is The Binding legal method
for creating graphical user interface
GUI in Python it is the only framework
included in the python standard library
in
fact so the next one
is first we will write here
import sorry from PK
enter
so
from PK
enter
for
file
dialog file dialogue TK enter provides a
number of built-in methods and class
Library function to create application
component and user actionable elements
one of the TK inter modules called file
dialogue offers classes and Library
functions for making windows for
selecting files and
dictionaries when you need to request
that a user browse a file or directory
on the system you can use file
dialogue so the next one
is
from TK
enter.
ttk
import combo box
combo box combines an entry field and a
list box one of the TK enter visits it
has down arrow to choose from a menu of
possibilities it aids consumer in
choosing from the list of available
options a pop off of a scrolling list
box it displayed down the entry field
when user clicks on the drop- down arrow
on the entry field only when option from
the list box is selected will the select
option be shown in the enter
field one
is it is one of the major One
Import
py TT
X
sx3
okay so a python text to speech
conversion library is called pyttsx3
it is compatible with python 2 and 3 and
works offline unlike competing libraries
to obtain a reference to a py TTX
Library engine instance an application
called the pytt X3 in it Factory method
it is a very userfriendly program that
turns type text to speech the saif5 for
windows program offers two voices that
the pytt sx3 module supports a female
voice and a male voice three TTS engines
are supported by it Windows sappy I5 NS
speech for Mac OS e speak is available
on all other
platform so the next one
is
import
OS so the OS module in Python has
function for adding and deleting folders
retrieving their contents changing the
directory locating the current directory
and more before you can communicate with
the underlying operating system you must
import the OS
module the next one
is
from
gtts
import
from play
sound
import
sound so gtts python has a variety of
apis that can turn text into speech the
Google text to speech API often known as
gtts API is one of these apis gtts is a
simple to use program that turns enter
text into audio that can be saved as MP3
file
languages including English Hindi Tamil
French German Spanish and many more are
supported via gtts
API any one of the two accessible audio
speeds Rapid or slow may be used to
deliver the speech theice of created
audio however cannot be changed as the
most recent
version so let me run
this so after importing major libraries
let's move forward and start creating
user interface
so I will write here import sorry root
equals
to
PK put dot
title simply
learn to speech
converter root dot
geometry I will give here
1,000
580 uh plus 200 from y axis
and then 80 from
Top okay root dot de
sizable we make it to like false false
and again
false okay
then
root.
configure background should be BG equals
to we use here
hash
F7
AC
then okay first I will explain this so
here TK stand for TK inter Library every
word in the string returned by the title
method begins with with an uppercase
letter like a title or a header the
following letter will be changed to
uppercase if the word contains a number
or a
symbol one of the built-in methods in TK
inter is geometry which is used to
specify Dimension while TK inter vigit
windows are mostly used to set the
application Windows Dimension
length the TK enter root Windows size
can be changed in accordance with the
needs of the user using the resizable
this
one
or we can forbid resizing of the TK
enter window in other words this
approach can be used to generate a
window with a defined size Simple Text
changes can be made to labels using
python TK inter config function two vets
are shown in the example
below a label and a button when the
button is pressed a function that is
attached to the button execute the label
config method you can give background
color as per your choice I've gave this
arrange something so let's run this and
see the first look of UI by writing here
I will write here
root dot main
loop I will run run all
yeah
okay so this is how our UI looks like
first UI so I can't resize because I
gave here false false I can't resize
it so if I will write
here set of false I will write here
true and
again through
here so then I will run
[Music]
again so now I can resize it as per my
choice okay yeah so I will write
here false and again
false
it okay let's move forward and add some
logos in the
application I have already some PNG
images on my system you guys can use any
picture of your choice I have some
images
here images
so you guys can use any picture of your
choice so I will write here like
simply _
logo was
to
photo
image
file then part of
file
CS SL
SLP 09
top
then ETS
folder s
folder
then simply do
PNG okay then I will set
label
put image equals
to Simply
image simply logo
sorry then
background I can copy from
here
do
place to 880 and Y AIS should
be like I will give here uh
okay let's run this
loot do main
Loop here there is something
error
search file
directory okay there is one now let me
run
this yeah now you can see simply learn
is there I need little bit
down so let me write again give here
39 run it
again
see okay now it's looking good
yeah the image object is returned by the
photo image function output it's that
easy to display a picture in Python
however the photo image class only
supports the GIF and PNG
images which is a concern
jpeg NG gpg and PNG are the formats that
are most often used the container box
where the text or images can be placed
is specified by the label the wiget is
used to inform the user or other wigets
that are utilized in the python
application the text or a portion of the
text shown in the label can be
configured using a number of different
parameters the root window is where all
the wigets are placed this one the root
window window is this all the widgets
are
placed even TK inter application must
include precisely one increase of the
class TK which is an instance of app is
a subass of frame and app is an instance
of app by positioning them in a precise
location with the parent visit the put
manager organize visits the option used
by the geometry manager are anchor
border mode height width real width x
and Y anchor shows the location where
the widget is
anchored okay let's move forward and add
logo here instead of this add One logo
here so I will make it comment
[Music]
down R it
yeah so for that I will write logo
uncore
image equals
to photo
image then
file
to we'll copy the path from
here it
here okay so let me change it to
speech. PNG perfect so
root dot icon photo
false for my
logo uncore
image put dot
main let me run
this yeah now you can see a logo here
so the image object is return by the
photo image function output it is the
easy to display a picture in Python
however the photo image class only
supports the GIF and PGM which is a
concern JPEG gpg and PNG are the formats
that are most often used the title bar
icon of the TK enter top level window is
set using the icon photo but in order to
set any image as a title bar icon it
must be an object of the photo image
class so okay logo is
added this logo is added now we will
make one upper frame like this one upper
frame till here something like here and
we will add the heading and logo in the
frame okay so let me do this let me make
it as a
command okay so I will write here upper
frame
to
frame then
root then background should
be you can use any color I will write
here #
a 7
DD cool then width should
be500 yes I can give it 1200 is
enough and height should
be 30 is
fine
upper M do
Place equals
to 0 and Y = 0 X and Y = to 0 why
because we need at the top
so I will add one picture there so
picture
was again
photo
image I can copy
from
yeah same image I will add then
label then when I'm where I'm adding
here is like
upper
frame image equals
to and
background should be the
same
and Dot
place = to
150 and Y should be like I will give
here
20 okay so let me run this root do main
Loop we'll run this run all yeah
okay okay there I have to
write y = to
again here what they sh f is
capital hope now now it will run
properly so the image is added here yeah
for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other wigets in a user
friendly manner the frame wiget is
crucial it functions like a container
that organizes the positioning of other
wigets to arrange the layout and provide
these wigets the screen uses rectangular
regions the root window is where all the
wigets are placed even TK enter
application must include precisely one
instance of the class TK and the label
is specifies the container box where the
text images can be placed these wigets
used to inform the user or the other
wigets that are utilized in the python
application the text or a portion of the
text shown in the label can be
configured using several different
parameters okay so logo is added and
it's looking great so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query
regarding any sort of code so just put
as in comment our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution I'm
repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
or if there are any question related to
python just put as in comments our team
will shortly provide you the correct
solution moving forward let's add a
heading to the application so I will
make it as a
command first I will add
[Music]
some cells
below better
view okay so for that I will write here
label I have to head adding at the upper
frame so I will write here upper
frame could be
will
give X
to
each
converter F should
be
new
Comm okay side should be 40 is enough I
guess and it should be
bold BG background color should
be I will add this one only so
copy paste it
here and foreground should
be
white and Dot place
at X = to
250 and Y should be the same I guess I
should
be I will write
to let's run this
root dot main
Loop okay
done
this okay it's like option
front Okay this is font
i f sorry my
bad how it will work I
guess yeah so here you can see text is
added so for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other wigets in user fling
manner the frame wiget is crucial it
function like a container that organize
positioning of the other wigets and the
label is specify the container box where
the text or images can be placed this
wigets used to inform the user of other
widgets that are utilized in the python
application and in TK enter there are
three different ways to specify a viget
type to put it simply use the string
format TK direct font format time 20
italic or
bold font family size styles is the
structure of the string where style can
be any legal mhup of text style
keywords okay so heading is added now
let's move forward and make a text box
for writing text to
it so let me make first this as a
command
okay so we are creating text box so I
will write here text
box equals
to
text then root window so I will write
here root
font so let me tell you first I will
create a text box like this or
this so font equals to
I
20 and background should be black or
white okay let's do black
first I did take it bite only
bite then relief is something relief
equals to
groove and uh
wrap eords into word or characters
word
word and Border width should be
zero okay so
text box do
place or should I place it x equals to
30A y =
to
150 comma
width
width should be I will make it the
longer one so I will write
here
940 then
height should be
so let's run this first root dot main
Loop let me run
it so yeah text box is created hello
guys
yeah so text box is created so the
python application uses the text visits
to display text Data the single line
text box is implemented using the entry
visits which TK enter offers the
multi-line style text is with a variety
of styles and characteristics is shown
using the text viset instead of group
you can use raised flat R and many more
it is used to make contact with within a
text document with using the r features
in TK inter we may include the
characters or words in the TK wigets you
can use word c or none are the available
default values for the W
properties the TK enter button BD option
determines the width or a stroke of the
border that encircles the button the
width of the border around a button can
be changed using the
BD so by positioning them in a precise
location with the parameter the put
manager organized visits the option used
by this geometry manager are anchor
border mode height width
X and Y and many more so our text box is
created can write
anything now let's move forward and add
some combo box for selecting voice and
speed so first I will what I will do it
I will make it
command here I will
write
gender box for male
female so equals
to
combo
box
put
value equals
to female
okay and font should
be could
be yeah font should be
r o b
o e then 12 sh should be 12 then there
is something called state to
R and
then
width
and gender
box but
place so I will PR something here
something here like gender should be
here and speed should be here
so I will write
here equals
to
40a Y =
400 then gender
box.
set to
mail run it so root do main
to let me run
this yeah so you can see male female
there this is combo box so a combo box
combines an entry field and a list box
one of the Tinker visits it has down
arrow to choose from a menu of
possibilities it aids consumers in
choosing from the list of available
option a pop off of a scrolling list box
it displayed down the entry field when
the user clicks on the drop- down arrow
on the entry field only when an option
from the list box is selected with the
selected option be shown in the entry
field if I will select here then it will
show female now
male so some variables supported by TK
enter can be used to change the values
of TK inter visits these variable
operates as a typical variable would the
values of these variable are set and
retrieved using the set and get
methods combo box combines a list box
wiget and an entry wiget you can choose
one value from a group of values using a
combo box widget you can also input a
custom value in
addition so set text is used to set the
text in the entry box in the python TK
enter it serves the purpose of entering
text into the entry box when used as a
function we will write a function
function and use as a button to invoke
it so okay so it's look great moving
forward let's add one more combo box for
the speed one like Fast medium and slow
so what I will do I will copy first I
will make it as a
command so first I will copy this and I
will paste it
here then I will
write speed box
again Heat box
again
box then I will set it to
medium and that there will be three
values
like
fast
and
slow and I will place combo
box where should I
place we'll place it
something like here I will place it here
so for
that I have to give X
as around
540 and why should be same so let me run
this and let's
see so yeah so it's looking fine
function I Ed here is same as the
previous one that we did for the gender
one for this one so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
any sort of code so just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution so moving
forward let's add play button to playing
the return txt but before that let's add
something called select voice and select
speed label for these two combo Bo for
like select select voice type and select
speed so let's add them quickly so I
will write here
label I am adding it to the root window
so I will write here root and text
equals
to
select voice
type and font
could
be
timesan and size should be like 15 is
enough I guess uh it should be
bold
Comm background color should be I will
here copy
past yeah foreground color should be
white or
place equals
to
340 and Y =
to 37
20 okay let me copy this for the
speed copy it and I will paste it here I
will write here
speed everything same cut it and I will
paste it here for the
running so let me run
this El speed is there I don't know
where you select okay okay I gave the
same X values I guess yeah so here I
have to write
540 let me run this
again yeah select voice male female
select speed fast medium
slow so the python application uses the
text visit to display the text Data the
single line text box is implemented
using the entry viget which TK enter
offers
the foreground color of a button is set
using the TK enter button FG parameter
alternatively the text color on the
button so it is looking cool now moving
forward let's add play button somewhere
here
so I will write code for
it
play
button
I have one photo for it
photo me copy the
path it
here
and light
Play and play
go
BTN was to
button
text equal to X should be
play there is something called
compound so that
left
Mage
to a
button comma background should
be
white and
width is
130 font
to
aial
hold border
width should
[Music]
be1 c means
centimeter and there is something called
command
to PE
now
say let
go etn
dot
Place X should
be
435 y should
let me see root do main
Loop can make it
comment okay okay okay so this is a
function we haven't created function yet
so I will add it at the
last so till see
see this border
width okay okay W
th I hope now it will
work TK
enter sorry my bad
yes
yeah so a python application can add
buttons by using the button vigit these
button can show text or images that
explain what they are for when a button
is
clicked you can connect a function or
method that is called automatically
using that command so here compound
determine the best way to display text
and an image or the label
cursor Define how the mouse will look
when it over the
wiget so the TK enter button BD option
control the Border width or stroke
surrounding the button and some TK inter
viets let you use command binding to
link a call back function to an event it
entails that you may specify a function
name in the widgets command option
so that it will be called whenever an
event occurs on the viset okay so our UI
for the text to speech converter
application is created and it is looking
fabulous so now let's add function for
converting the text to speech sound let
me write the code first and then I will
explain you line wise okay now we can
write
here command equals
to
speak
now
okay so what I will do I will add a
function
here I will add function
here so let me write the code first then
I will explain you line wise lies so
here I will write TTS TTS is nothing
just text to speech variable pytt sx3
do
init EF for function speak
now XT equals to text underscore box dot
get
1.0 till the
end gender equals
to
Tender
Box dot
get and speed equals to
speedcore
box dot
get
voices equal to TTS do
property
voices okay so there is one another
function set
voice
if gender to equals
to
male TTS
dot set
property
should be
Capital
Property yeah
voice The Voice ID voices ID should be
Z do
ID
TS do say whatever written on
text
PS
dot
run run
and I'm done for then
else
pts dot
set property
voice
voes do
ID pts do
say
text and again TTS
dot done and
so by here I will for I will write code
for that speed if
text and again
if speed plus to equals to
fast then pts do
set
property and
rate rate should
be
250 at two
voice if
or else if
speed Al equals
to
M so then ETS dot set
property and rate should
be
150 set voice function will be
called
else TTS do
set
property itts dot set property then rate
should
be eight should
be
that
voice okay so function is created dog
dog get property find text okay now let
me run
this yeah so let me explain you pts is
nothing just a variable to text to
speech and in it py TTS X3 engine has
started obtains a pointer to an instance
of an engine that will utilize the
specified driver if another engine
instance is already using the given
driver the other engine instance is
returned if not a new engine is
built so speak now is a function which
using get function I'm getting the
values of the text box voice I will show
you
wait
so from this
from this is speak now I'm getting the
value of text male and female then
speed and using the get property I'm
getting the voices of male and female in
set voice what I did using ID zero for
male and assenting into the male and
using ID 1 for female and assigning it
to the
female and in this LC flader I'm setting
speed to a particular values using the
rate function and assigning them speed
in frames per second so now let's see
text to speech converter is working or
not so what I will write here
hello
coders
welcome to Simply
learn so I will
play Hello coders welcome to simple
learn
hope you hear the
sound I repeat hope you heard the sound
then same thing I will from from
female okay object run and
wait okay there is an
error run and wait
I will
write let me run this
again hello simply
learn hello simple
learn and again with female
voice hello simple
learn will write here hello simply
Learners
subscribe to our
YouTube
channel
hello simple Learners subscribe to our
YouTube
channel then I will play it to
fast hello simple Learners subscribe to
our YouTube channel then I will play to
slow hello simple
Learners subscribe to our YouTube
[Music]
channel
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you want to become an AI expert and
gain handsome salary packages look at
the wide range of eiml courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe so what
are you waiting for hurry up and enroll
now an year of experience is preferred
to enroll in these courses find the
course Link in the description
Box open CV open source computer vision
library is an open source computer
vision and machine learning software
Library it is WR in C++ but has a
binding for various programming
languages such as python Java MLB open
CV was designed with a goal of providing
a common infrastructure for computer
vision applications and to accelerate
the use of machine learning perception
in commercial product open CV is widely
used in the variety of indues including
robotics automative and Healthcare it's
supported by a large community of
developers researchers and users who
contribute to its development and
provide support to its users it is
supported by a large community of
developers researchers and users who
contribute to its development and
provide supports to its users so now
let's see what is object detection
object detection is a computer vision
technology that involves identifying and
localizing the object of interest within
an image or a video it is a challenging
task as it involves not only recognizing
the presence of an object but also
detecting its precise location and size
within the image or video object
detection algorithm typically used deep
learning techniques such as CNN to
analyze the image or video for
identifying the objects these algorithm
can also determine the boundaries of the
object by drawing a bounding box around
them so after understanding what is
object detection now let's move on to
the programming part so this is a kernel
python kernel here we will change this
name so here I will write object
detection
demo Okay so
so first we will import some major
Library like open CV so for that we will
write import CV2 and the next one is
import M plot
lib P
plot as PLT so why we are writing PLT
because we can't write again and again M
plot li. P plot okay it's a long one so
we can write a short form
PLT so yeah
so let's run this so what is opencv
opencv is an open source software
library for computer vision and machine
learning the open CV full form is open
source computer vision Library it was
created to provide a shared
infrastructure for application for
computer vision and to speed up the use
of machine learning perception in
consumer products open CV as a BSD
license software make it simple for
companies to use and change the code
okay so there are some predefined
packages and libraries that make our
life simple and and open CV is one of
them second one is mat BL Li mat BL Li
is a easy to use and an amazing
visualize library in Python it is built
on numpy array and designed to work with
broader CPI stack and consist of several
plots like line bar scatter histogram
and many others okay so moving forward
we will import our file okay so here I
will write
config file equals to this is our file
name SSD
uncore
mobilet
V3
large
Coco
202 14.
BB okay so you can find this file on the
description box below
Frozen model equals
to I explain you every single
thing
inference
graph. PV okay so let me run it first
mobile net as a name applied the mobile
net model is designed to use in mobile
application and it's tflow first mobile
computer vision model mobile net used
depthwise separable convolutions it
significantly deduces the numbers of
parameter when compared to the network
with regular convolutions with the same
depth in the NS this result in the
lightweight of the deep neural network
so mobile net is a class of CNN that was
open source by Google and therefore this
gives us an excellent starting point for
training our classifiers that are
insanely small and insanely fast okay so
what is this large Coco this is a data
set Coco data set like with applications
such as object detection segmentation
and captioning the Coco data set is
widely understood by the
state-of-the-art of neural network its
versatility and the multi-purpose scene
variation serve best to train a computer
vision model and Benchmark its
performance okay so what is coko the
common object in context is one of the
most popular large scale label images
data set available for public use it
represent a handful of object we
encounter on a daily basis and contains
image notations in 80 categories I will
show you the categories I have with over
1.5 million object instances okay so
modern day AI driven solution are still
not capable of producing absolute
accuracy and result which comes down to
the fact that coko data set is a major
Benchmark for CV to train test and
polish refined models for faster scaling
of The annotation Pipeline on the top of
that the Coco data set is a supplement
to transfer learning where the data used
for one model serves as a starting point
for the another so what is frozen
insurence graph like freezing is the
process to identify and save all the
required graphs like weights and many
others in a single file that you can
usually use a typical transl model
contains four files and this contains a
complete graph okay so forward let's
create one model here I will write model
to CV2 do
DNN model
chenel and then config
file so here I'm giving the parameters
two parameters like frozen model and
config
file score here yeah run it first okay
there is error
return okay so error is CV2 DNN
detection model return is
result an exception set the question
comes what is the meaning of deduction
model or DNN deduction model so this
class represent the high level API for
object detection networks detection
models allows to set parameters for
pre-processing input image detection
model creates net from file and with
train weights and config sets it
processing input runs forward pass and
return the result
deductions okay moving forward let's set
the class
labels okay
class
labels file
name to labels.
dxt I will put this file on the
description box below you can download
from there
open file
name
as
labels this
St
so here I created one array of name
class labels so this is the file name
what I'm doing I'm putting this label
file into these class labels okay so
here if I will
print class
labels so these are the 80 categories in
the Coco data
set okay this person bicycle car
motorbike aerplane bus train these all
are the a
categories I will put this file label.
txt in the description box below you can
find download from there okay
fine so let's print the length of the
Coco data set or you can see class
labels
this 80 as you can see I have already
told
you the length will be
0 so here let's set this some model
input size scaling mean and all so I
will write here model dot set
putut
size 320 comma
do
set
input
scale
1.0 SL
127.5 okay I will explain you don't
worry model do
set
input
[Music]
mean
127.5 comma
127.5 okay and then model do
set
input
we
B will
be what is set input
size
okay so set input size is a size of new
frame a shape of the new blob less than
zero okay so this is the size of the new
frame the second one is set input scale
the set input scale is a scale factor of
the value for the frame or you can say
the parameter will be the multiplier of
the frame values or you can say
multiplier for the frame values okay so
input mean so it set the mean value for
the frame the frame in which the photo
will come the video will come or my
webcam will come so it set the mean
value for the frame or the for
parameters mean scalar with the mean
values which are subtracted from the
channels you can see and the last one is
set input swap RB so it set the flag
swap RB for the every frame we don't
have to put every time a single frame
for a particular image it will be set
the true for the all the images
okay so parameters will be swap I'll be
flag which indicates the swap first and
the last channels so moving forward we
will Port one
image I am
read bo.
jpg
do I am
show
so this is the size of 320x 320 okay so
first thing is you can download this the
random picture from the Google I took
from Google itself so now what we will
do we will set the class
index the confidence
value
value the B box B box is the boundary
box which I will create for that
particular person cycle motorbike and
the car okay equal to
model the confidence
threshold threshold is used
for if my model will confirm it's the
particular image which is the texting is
correct it will print the name okay
so let me
print
Plus Class index is coming 1 2 3
4 okay so one means person two means
Bicycle three means car and four means
motorbike this is the class index index
for particular label what I will do I
will print the
boxes
font
scale = to 3 and the font equals to CV2
dot font
her
plane
for
class index and the confidence and the
boxes
and Dot
P
conf
that
box the boundary
box
okay then I will write here CV2 do
rectangle to make the
rectangle set the
image and
boxes five comma 0 comma 0 this is the
color of the box and this will be the
thickness
okay then I will write CV2 dop
put
text image
then class
labels I will write class index minus
one because always index start with zero
that's why and the box
is
zero
and comma
boxes
one
4 okay
F
comma
scale font
scale
coloral
to this will be the text color 0 comma
255 comma
0 and the
thickness three let me run
it uh no error okay now PLT do I am
show then CV2 do
CVT
color
then
cvt2 dot
color color then
BGR to
brg that is why we wrote swap RB equals
to true because every time we will
convert BGR to
brg sorry GB RGB so we don't have to
write again and again it will convert
all the files into RGB okay run
it okay as you can see the motorbike is
coming
bicycle is coming the person is coming
the car will car is coming okay so it's
detecting the
right for the image now we will do this
for the video and for the
webcam we are done with this image one
and then now I will write
here okay so this is will do for the
video for the video I will write here
cap equals to capture you can write any
name so CV2
dot
video
capture so you can take any random video
I took this
pexels
George can comment
down
share the
link have dot is
open so here I will write
cap equals
to
CV2 sorry CV2
dot
video
capture
zero and if
not cap dot is
open
then and
raise input output
error
can't open the
video can't open the
video here everything will be the same
font
scale = to
3 okay font equals to CV2
dot
front
her okay so here I will write while
true comma
frame equals to cap dot sheet
this is for the reading of the
file the same I will write class
index comma
confidence boundary
boxum model do
detect flame and the
confidence
threshold to
0.55 okay every thing is the same we did
before so here I will
print
class
index okay so here I will write
if
and of the class
index does not equals to
zero
then what to perform is here I have to
write
for class
index comma
confidence comma
boxes
insip
CL index do
flatten flatten is a layers okay
confides
flatten e
box and
if
class index is greater than equals to
then what to do then I will copy from
here
okay the same thing I have to write
here so here I will write CV2 Dot I am
sure this will be the return in the
frame object
detection by simply
learn and
frame so if CV2 dot vit
key
and 0o
FFX =
to
o q okay
then here I will write
break will be break when it get into two
the weight key will be two okay I will
tell you what is the weight
key here I will write cap dot release
is and CV2
dot
destroy
all
windows
okay so now let me
run let's see error there will be error
okay
see Python Programming
modules let me run it
again the
keys
okay video is
here the video is here as you can see
see bicycle the person the person the
bus car traffic light the person person
so our object object detection for the
video is coming right okay person okay
person traffic light
buz this is how you can do for the video
okay so now let's we will do for the uh
webcam
live so this is for the video
so if we want to do for the webcam we
okay so we need to just
change one one thing only we have to
change instead of giving the file we
have to write one here okay the rest
will be the
same got it so I have to just shut down
my webcam so let me shut down the webcan
and get back to
you
as you can
see this is a 320x 320 box
so so this is coming right okay so I if
I will show this the mobile phone is
coming right now okay so this is how you
can do the correct object detection and
with that we have come to the end of
this video on AI ml projects full course
I hope you found it useful and
entertaining please ask any questions
about the topic covered in this video in
the comment section below our experts
will assist you in addressing your
problems thanks for watching stay safe
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here